coming to you in five four three two
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast live
remember everybody you never helped Bob
Barker used to say remember new to your
dog so I want to point raised here
because I just came from the bathroom oh
yeah remember everybody wash your hand
because every time I'm in the bathroom
there's some nasty I swear to god people
have taking dumps next to me in that
bathroom and not wash their hand so I'm
pointing this new phrase but remember
everybody wash your hands
you big germaphobe boy I'm a low tier
I'm half time germaphobe I think I I'm
sneezing a hand [ __ ] that's a dead no
for me though like even just a little or
little coughing your hands like I'm not
I'm not touching you you know well I
don't blame me because when I sneeze and
when I sneeze that's like a waterfall I
mean there's so much yeah I'm out of me
yeah but I'm not I'm not totally I mean
I am a germ guy but I also think that if
you take a [ __ ] and the public stall you
should wash your hands you got it even
if you go pee in there like as soon as
you walk through the threshold you have
the obligation visually to wash or at
least do if there's visitors in there
with you do them the courtesy of the
theatre of Washington yes you know what
I don't do though for public bathrooms
if I'm alone and if I go to the urinal I
don't wash my hands because they say
logically if I'm well if I'm alone and
no one's in there I don't wash my hands
in the public bathroom because my
rationale is like if I'm flushing with
my foot you know so the only thing I'm
touching is like my zipper what about
your and it falls out get urine on your
fiber if I pee on my finger then I'll
wash it was I that happens a lot to me
really I don't know what I don't know I
have a pretty good aim my hands all over
the place yeah because I'm kind of I'm
like neurotic and I forced the urine out
of my dick oh yeah like I'll pee more
than I have to because I hate the
feeling of having to pee that's true do
you ever get like gun-shy and [ __ ]
though like oh yeah I can't go if anyone
else is in there I've gotten better and
my older age but
as like pretty much up until recently
and even sometimes recently if there's
someone next to me yeah I'm going to I'm
waiting for this doll yeah I can't do it
can't do it isn't that interesting I
don't know why cuz it doesn't tie into
any other areas of confidence like no
matter how confident you get just like
[ __ ] I don't know and they're just like
they know I'm not peeing right now right
it's been five seconds like I don't loud
here goddamn but I had a real complex
about it and like when I was in high
school mm-hm
or yeah well when you're in a setting
and there's lots of people there and
it's like real quiet yeah and you can
definitely hear if they're paying or not
that drives me crazy yeah see the thing
is though too
I think a tweeted about this last week
one of my greatest assets now as I
became an adult was like the ability to
poop wherever like I can just take a
[ __ ] wherever any public baths really 20
people in there I don't care but like
looking at a urinal I can't do it
because you've got privacy in the
[ __ ] at least ya do unless they're
you know unless it's sometimes you may
get a little bit of pekin action going
on people not figure that out I don't
know it's some countries they have the
stalls figured out you could engineer it
beautifully or you could just get some
bris Brussels that's it just some
Brussels that cover the crack courtesy
Brussels yeah Curtis they have those in
Brussels actually you know like a
paintbrush the Brussels the bristles it
just covers it like it's on the bottom
of doors and [ __ ] yeah you can't see
through the Brussels it's not a big
investment no standard practice yeah but
I'll still [ __ ] you're right yeah I
think I think that's an interesting
conversation I think we should explore
that mm-hmm but first I'd like to first
of all introduce you oh yeah our guest
today is if you haven't yet guess Gus
Johnson all scooo stuff is your phone
number yes Swedish Norwegian boy okay
and your brother's name is Sven yeah so
are you guys like fresh off the boat or
what this is a strong no my parents want
to do some deep cuts because I've got
I've got my other brothers name is Thor
Johnson you have a sword in your family
got a Thor off Johnson which lets that a
badass
how does he how has he developed in life
as a Thor he's a strong presence blonde
hell he's big athlete guy
yeah and Sven is fen Iver Johnson which
is dope I really got the short end of
the stick on the name game my the Gustav
school it's like a regal King kind of
thing but my middle name is it spelled
EMI L how would you assume that's pretty
mi l yeah
like ml or a meal or something right
it's pronounced a Mille so it looks like
email and it sounds like anal and it's
like who the [ __ ] is naming anal yeah
whenever that's why my I've kind of
outed myself now on Twitter and stuff
like I'm cost danger Johnson and stuff
and whenever people would ask me
grown-up like what's your middle name I
just feel like danger and they go haha
and not ask again cuz I was like I'm
gonna tell kids that my name is anal I'd
be dead on the playground if I do that
[ __ ] that'd be stupid yeah you want to
keep that a secret
yeah let me out let me let me say
something to you
what would you think about a child whose
actual middle name was danger was danger
oh that's a good point I'd probably hate
him more because and I'm sure he's not
listening so I'm not worried but I have
a cousin I shouldn't even say I should
have said I know the information is so
it's a specific that you could never
possibly know I have a cousin who named
his first son his middle name is danger
okay
it's not it's not as terrible well I'm
setting you up clearly but I have a
strong opinion about it I mean like you
don't even know the guys you know if to
work but I think it's awful that's true
you have to seem it like Thanksgiving or
something he doesn't listen okay he
doesn't [ __ ] danger I mean it's like
damn because if my middle name was
danger I'd almost want to keep that a
secret as anal I don't know the thing is
though my mentality was like playground
kid thing like if you're danger
kids would probably be like whoa you
know but for really you know you're dead
in the water yeah that's a good point
you're so dead in the water
then also want to thank our sponsors cut
away from us Robin Hood hems and audible
give it up I also want to observe want
to observe that Gus Johnson here funny
man
comedian gives their gaffe sir musician
heck of a fungi oh you I'm on the brink
is on the brink of 1 million subscribers
if you look at the screen here we're at
nine hundred ninety five thousand four
hundred and eighty two now
1 million is a that's the big one that's
the big one that's kind of the last
milestone for a while
honestly all the millions are kind of
the same ten is the only other one that
I'm yeah why mailing it to you know it's
like oh oh well the million dumbass yeah
so you know what's gonna happen this is
gonna go one of either way either the
community's gonna go like let's get him
there or there'd be like a [ __ ] bees
live let's take the numbers well now
that you said that yeah what are you
gonna do right no I wanted to I wanted
to offer Gus the h3 bump okay we want to
give him the h3 bump that is the
endorsement that is the gold seal if you
do not know who Gus is if you're not a
fan here now there it is see the people
respond to the call we're bumping we're
about getting high on h3 so everyone
who's watching if you're not subscribed
to Gus first of all let me just tell you
you'll be doing yourself a huge favor by
subscribing to this guy okay and even if
you don't like him no see you just went
back down
goddamnit you guys what the hell how did
it go up and then down something like
how did they collude oh they pranked me
there do yourself a favor for Christ's
sake okay and subscribe to Gus let's get
them to bump guys let's get them to 1
million oh all right thanks for the bump
fellas appreciate it yeah we'll check
back in on that so you had your first
anxiety attack you mentioned to me is
that something you've talked about
publicly um I can't remember if I
mention it on my own podcast the Gus and
Eddie podcast it was like a month ago or
so I haven't really talked on it too
publicly I've never really had like a
bunch of anxiety [ __ ] to my knowledge
before but like stuff has been so
stressed
last few months and I know I have super
high blood pressure and I eat pizza for
like every [ __ ] meal mmm that's some
good [ __ ] but getting there yeah I don't
know I know my diets not super good and
I had a lot like my first live show
stuff was coming up but I just got hit
like a [ __ ] ton of bricks like a
month ago we were driving to go see
spider-verse with some buddies and I
just all of a sudden I couldn't breathe
and my chest was all tight and I
couldn't feel my face and like my speech
was really slowed down like that I was
like what the [ __ ] is going on I thought
I was having a heart attack or something
so into the emergency room and chest
x-ray and everything they're like yeah
you had an anxiety attack
yes and then like the two weeks after
that you kept feel it come on a little
bit like oh [ __ ] it's coming on it's
going on so I don't know what that's all
about but luckily no less I don't think
I mean interesting here's the thing I've
been through that yeah it's not it
probably has nothing to do with the food
you know you think no because I eat some
higher let's hang out we'll both be dead
by the age of 40 it's everything that's
my thing either goes to me she goes be
just boring pizza beat she goes pizzas
boring I'm like I don't even know you
it's not though if how are you human
that's inhuman thing to say it's so that
is literally you are not you are a
reptilian it's pretty like crickets yeah
what do you mean crafted there's so many
little variations on the theme it's like
a Mozart symphony like well if you say
okie today maybe some Gabriella's today
you know and then you put Tapatio on it
when it starts getting a little cooler
like what you do oh really oh hell yeah
you got a few I just dip it in ranch I
can't do that see yeah let's not hang
yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah you got to
find your spot yeah he'd say okay that's
my groove see you have better options
cuz you're you're in the city we're in
the valley and the valley there's just a
lot of scammers
really get your top hundred dollars for
some shitty pieces but let me ask you
what your well I want to talk more about
the anxiety but let's get to really the
you know what's important here what do
you what do you put on your PI put on
the PI here are you pepperoni boy I'm a
pepperoni boy for the most part I had a
feeling yeah locked you ready do I drink
Coca Cola classic not diet right um I do
diet no but yeah well I switch to diet
more after the anxiety attacks and I'm
healthiest shits though right yeah fixed
it
I do pepperoni and jalapeno for the most
part that's that good stuff okay so what
I find the pepperoni to be a little too
heavy and greasy for me although I love
it what I like to do is black all of is
my pepperoni
you'll ya lost me suck okay we agreed on
the pizza but when you get down to it we
are just completely we can not we have
to walk separate ways it is fun because
for me I think black olives black black
olives mushrooms like most classic combo
Oh fertile and I'm feeling like really
adventurous I want black olives I want
jalapenos we agree there but if I really
am feeling like if I'm ordering a Pete
if I'm by myself yeah this is the pizza
I'm getting because I know nobody else
wants yeah black olives jalapeno and
pineapple oh my god that's like
scientifically designed Turing everybody
else protection that's my [ __ ] I don't
have to tell you I love it I dip it in
rain you know it's crazy I don't mind
that one so I know because it's
delicious because your your your you
know your gut reaction was like oh oh I
only eat pepperoni yeah but that you
don't right though I don't know if I had
my way the perfect relaxation thing and
this ties back into like calm and
anxiety [ __ ] if I had my way every
single night of my life if it had no
health repercussions I would have a few
beers I would just just destroy my body
on pizza watch the office and fall
asleep with 20 minutes after I got done
eating it
it's my groove you know it's perfectly
calming that should so unhealthy for you
though so I got that a shame I wish so
much danced saying I'm a psycho yeah
well at least I like pizza honestly I
don't want to scare you guys but i would
probably enjoy more just eating a
cucumber like what I'm just a rock you
comfort eat it like an you know it's
[ __ ] up I would leave her it's no I'm
fine cucumber too by itself pretty
offensive yeah like just says something
to eat on like a pickle like a just a
cucumber I find that to be pretty
offensive yeah that's some bad [ __ ] I
love it about it I mean good for you I
wish I love cucumber more than pizza
being a lot my life would be in a lot I
mean yeah but I dream of a future my
utopian future is when they
scientifically engineer pizza to be like
healthy they could so easily pieces
there you got cheese and whole grain and
veggies and [ __ ] but somehow
government's holding us back
yeah it's the government [ __ ] loved
ones that you know what I when I really
want to go crazy those bait out put
bacon on it
yeah bacon and black olives that's see I
could screaming we get together
I'll go bacon and we can go jalapeno
alright that's our mid that's our treaty
like that's a solid pie right that's a
solid pie you definitely be hurt in the
next morning but it's solid pepperoni I
mean that's just as bad at anything yeah
that's like drinking a Duracell battery
for you much yeah I mean [ __ ] when you
get pepperoni you got to get out like a
paper towel and dab that [ __ ] yeah
that's nasty I need a shower after 8:00
anyway yeah so when I first start having
my anxiety attacks I was like oh it's
cuz I'm its you know the food and I
don't exercise so I start like running
and changing my diet and everything but
it's really it's not you know
in my opinion because I've been through
this it's uh thirst there's its other
issues mm-hmm it's psychological issues
that cause that not if it's not food and
stuff you know as I understand it ya
know I think I just got to lock down my
schedule stuff the thing is like for
years I've always just sort of barely
made it by stuff you know like I barely
got out of high school I barely
graduated college and I got like a 2.5
when I graduated like just trip my way
out the door so now that like I have
this built-up barely making it mentality
but I'm taking on new projects with like
other people that really rely on me it's
just stress on the outer so much more
yeah it was just so much easier like
when you when I was just kind of [ __ ]
around back in small town Wisconsin just
like y'all make a meme this week I'll do
that but now it's like should I have
people to answer to and people rely on
me and stuff like yeah [ __ ] I hate that
so much but it takes time really more oh
yeah yeah I I've had a pretty rough week
because I'm like Teddy fresh has grown a
lot and I'm super happy and proud but it
comes with so much work and like like
you said I'm working with people now so
I gotta respond and I gotta be there and
like I was thinking to this week just
when we first started it was just
awesome like we wasn't a product manager
yeah we had one employee there wasn't
really any stress and I'm like how did
we even do stuff back then oh it's so
complicated now we have four full-time
employees and we're like more stressed
about it Jesus but but I I think I went
through kind of the same thing it's like
I always see my there's like mental
barriers that I kind of hit mm-hmm
there's like new walls that I'm always
hitting and then you got it just push
through it and get over it
mm-hmm yeah totally yeah I think therapy
is good because it's hard to figure out
what is actually what actually is it you
know what I'm saying that's a good point
I think back I was gonna ask you to like
what were some things that you guys did
what like earlier on to make money and
stuff cuz I was thinking or like dude
well I know you talked about what I saw
literally I sucked it yeah a lot of them
oh gee fire festival mode there
I didn't hell yeah dude you know this
because I was just thinking like back to
like what I was talking about the easier
early days I went to just a small
College in Wisconsin UW Stout and I used
to just I felt like I appreciated little
things more and like a little bits of
money and in projects as people stuff
you know what I used to do was it was a
few years ago early on is I'd get some
buddies together for a weekend and I
figured out that through break calm you
remember break that's just old video
sharing website for you to be stuff
mm-hmm a dude I've reached out to me
from break comm like four years ago I
was just like hey I'd like to buy this
clip or whatever for like a hundred
dollars or so ya know what I'm super
like oh boy my stuff so I did that and
then I I circled back then I was like
hey you guys I could just sell you [ __ ]
eclipse like I can just pump stuff out
he's like yeah okay we'll do that you go
he's what the big thing for them was
like they would always do these prank
compilations and scare videos and stuff
like that
and he's like yeah you know you send us
any of those we'll give you like 50 100
bucks to the video so what I would I
would I would get some buddies together
for a weekend we get like four or five
guys get a couple different cameras like
an old shitty cell phone at DSLR or like
a Sony flip cam so everything looks
different I would we everyone would
trade out being like the person getting
scared the guy scaring and the person
behind the camera so we would rotate
every variation of these and it would
always be for me I was like I don't want
my [ __ ] face out there on these
horrible ass Frank video so wasn't
ironic or funny you were literally
taking beat
yeah just like oh I'm gonna crank these
out so it's always made a great channel
with that right that's where blowing up
he doesn't own that contact yep
exclusive rights get good that's awesome
so there's probably like dozens of stuff
out there that like you guys are anybody
else might have seen like a prank and
shitty little scare video in a
compilation and it's like me from far
away with a ball cap on or something I
was undercover with that that's awesome
so I would sell him off and then split
it with my buddies you know I that beats
selling drugs what we were doing ya know
when we were
starting to make videos on YouTube and
then we had like a small following I
started to I would for example sell a
sticker pack that I made and good we
were hustle like cars ela was basically
Chinese sweat factor and I don't know if
you have seen the Jeff [ __ ] dolls oh
yeah those little pink so those things
supported us back in their day yeah
yellow and now that I think back about
it it's like I mean we charge $40 a dude
and it took me a lot of water was
spending and then we would we would take
a bunch of them we would walk to the
post office sit there for hours yeah it
was like I swear that I would I would
sit there editing and he'll be on the
couch behind me sewing Jeff Dunham [ __ ]
but I loved it and just the fact that I
could make money any amount of money
doing that and not like wait working as
a waitress or as a babysitter anything
miracle than that was amazing to me so I
was oh yeah I was like we were at home
together we won't go at working with
some other [ __ ] I had a date I worked
at a day job for five years in a desk
job so for me the same I was making like
$1,000 a month and I was just like cuz
before I quit my job I was working on
YouTube events I was making like $1,000
a month when I quit my job but I was
just like hmm that's my rent yeah yeah I
missed that stuff like going through
high school in college like I just
worked in food service a lot I was a
pizza guy for a while he's the guy he's
never do it act yeah it's see that's why
it's its genetic at this point I was a
pizza delivery guy in the meth producing
capital of the entire United States what
they order on their pies they ordered
well I don't remember what they ordered
but they tipped like goddamn kings did I
genuinely all the time I would deliver
to like meth dens did you ever get
crystals and I was I was offered drugs a
couple times as tips yeah like little
bags of crisps I smoked some meth yeah I
was like oh my boss no dude it was it
was rough I one time I delivered to a
house that had just been broken into and
it was clearly the guys that broke into
the house that ordered the pizza to
because I'm from a town of like a
thousand a people oh that's next level
yeah it was [ __ ] scary so they went
out there and the the girl that was
doing the phones when she took the
delivery she goes like oh that's weird
they asked for your full name I was like
really it was it like a relative I don't
know so I just gave it to him hold on
stay away hold on oh look they ordered
the pie yeah then asked for the delivery
guys full name or yes that's what they
did they said what's the delivery guys
full name that's Johnson so but I mean I
wasn't tipped off yet this was way out
of town so I'm going out there and it
was one of the only houses on this road
it was January and I Drive up and
there's a running like pickup truck in
the front yard the front door was busted
off its hinges so I was like what the
[ __ ] is going on so I walk up to the
front door and it's like they look like
the two dudes in home alone there's a
guy with like with a jacket on and the
fingerless gloves and he was hacking up
dining-room tables and like starting a
fire in the in the fireplace was like
furniture and [ __ ] so I like walk up
tonight old yeah I was [ __ ] freezing
so he just was like starting a fire in
this cabin and like I walk up and I
stockers it Hey pizza's here and he
stands up hey hey what's going on what's
going on got the pizza oh okay hey Dan
pizza whatever the dude's name was this
guy comes around he goes hey and the
total was like I don't know fifteen
dollars and he's like what I oh yeah
fifteen bucks he goes okay he pulls open
a backpack and he pulls open a big like
gallon ziplock bag of just crumpled
hundred-dollar bills
oh my god and he reaches in there and he
pulls out like a fifty which is you know
like thirty five dollar tip or whatever
that's huge and he goes like here you go
keep the change
Gus Johnson oh my so it's just like your
[ __ ] like and rat me out I would they
even bother like yeah like bring your
love for a minute yeah Jesus Wow but
you're probably so you're probably equal
parts stoked and scared
yeah I was like hey money but also they
know my own name and location yeah cuz
it's like what if they get found out
they're gonna blame it on the pizza guy
what an easy scapegoat like
but also man that's a wild scene I
wonder if that's their plan B just to
blame it on the pizza guy it could be I
mean if you're looking for someone to
kill it's easy to offer pizza kid so it
wasn't us it was Gus he's got some of
the money check the serial code yeah but
that should happen all the time you know
like you'd go up and there were times we
delivered a little shacks that didn't
even have a fire number and like dudes
would come out and there was honestly it
looked like Breaking Bad like they had
full hazmat suits hanging outside the
door they come to the door and a wife
beater and a cigarette and it smelled
like chemical fireable Rottweilers in
the background like that should happen
all the time it was really good there
those are the good days that's what I
miss no but I think I agree that
everyone's got the good days yeah and
I'll tell you even your fans they look
back on there was the golden days
actually we have several golden day
faces for different fans and even I look
back in I reminisce but you know you
know sometimes you just got to have a
slice and enjoy the present moment yeah
just be nice it's a doobie no I used to
are you feeling are you feeling like
you're missing what is it like the
content is it the vibe but what is it
that you're missing about the old days
the thing is I and I think a lot of
people might agree hopefully that in the
last six months to a year especially I
have felt the proudest of my content I
think it's the best that it's been in
the four years that I've been doing this
kind of full-time ish but I just I
missed I missed the peace of mind and
the simplicity and stuff you know it was
so every it was [ __ ] no expectations
yeah like even like going through
college like right I had about a year
and a half of college left when that
first big ad pocalypse hit you know and
I was maybe off of youtube and patreon
insured stuff so maybe making like seven
hundred bucks a month but then it cost
me $200 for rent everything included in
my college house I was like I get a few
hundred dollars like I can go buy ten
Romo pizzas for eight bucks you know
among friends you're probably the
richest hey guys I got this round of $2
shots yeah
you know like everybody says everything
was dope you know I used to I used to
when we moved out for the college end of
the semester [ __ ] you know the dorms all
have these donation bins at my college
and all the building managers would tell
people they said hey if you want
anything out of here you just dig in you
go for it you know but I felt
embarrassed like going in like taking
the food and electronics and stuff so
what I used to do is I would I would go
to sleep at 8:00 p.m. and I would wake
up at 3 in the morning I'd grab my
roller blades go down to campus with a
duffel bag and a backpack and I would be
listening to just like podcasts and [ __ ]
and I would I would fill up my duffel
bag full of food and electronics and
stuff and then I would flip the
electronics in the daytime be like hey
someone want a box fan five bucks or
like and then I had like a year's worth
of food and [ __ ] you know like that was
that was pure bliss for me dumpster
diving and stuff like that and just
making memes whenever making twenty five
dollars on a video or something like I
love that let me ask you this because I
often think this to myself yeah there's
a time like when mean either were living
back in Santa Cruz that we think back
and we have that vibe of like oh man
that was just the best most carefree
vibe but then I have specific memories
then I remember and I'm like oh wait we
were miserable then you know it's it's
easier to romanticize to when you look
at a situation that seems like it has
fewer consequences because you're like
what happened if I messed up then you
know I'll just go wash dishes again at
the campus cafe stuff you know but also
I was [ __ ] miserable I was waking up
at 5 a.m. making omelets for shitty
college kids and you know failing all my
classes having to beg professors for
grades and stuff like good I want to
told her professor this is I once told
someone that I my god did this was
Isaac's idea by the way I was gonna
flunk out of college for the second time
yeah and I'm gonna flunk
I mean fail out of university and I told
them I just found out that my this is so
[ __ ] up that I did this I just
remember this I told them that I just
found out my girlfriend has HIV
oh my god yeah he said to me never cross
my mind he goes you know I have a friend
who did this and they got an extension
and I was like oh my god
so I went and I sat in front of the
council or whatever and I was like yeah
I know I'm feeling all my classes but oh
my god I found out my girlfriend has HIV
that's a rough one you know again the
middle ground or something yeah that was
I that's the awful thing I like just
remember yeah yeah I want fall cucumber
I had a couple of shameful ones though
were like that so I'm embarrassed to
admit that story I like the biggest
thing for me was like I I knew going
through college I was so [ __ ]
terrible that stuff especially like
getting an art degree I can't draw I
can't paint nothing that you've studied
yeah like they they hung it in her line
well it was when I went there there was
like I'll come to this this is the only
dude film degree in Wisconsin that you
can get this not at the uw-madison like
yeah you be the next Spielberg and [ __ ]
but then they go oh 80% of your classes
are going to be drawing and painting I
was like I went to my first audio
engineering class like audio design when
I was a junior in college and we sit
down the first day the professor goes
okay so we're gonna be working primarily
with audacity in this class the [ __ ]
audacity of him to suggest that [ __ ] but
like it's just it was a it was a joke of
a film degree met so many wonderful
people I was solely responsible for my
shitty grades take full responsibility
but I just like I didn't want to draw
and paint I couldn't do that [ __ ] yeah
so there were so many times where it's
the end of the semester and it's like in
one of my like drawing classes or
something I go to the professor and I
hadn't turned in a single thing all year
and just like I don't have to tell you
like I [ __ ] up I have AIDS like
you can owe to tell you like don't want
to sound like an ultimatum at all the
reality is if I fail this class I don't
know when I can fit it in again I might
have to drop out of college I'm sorry to
put that on you whoa like January
yeah I'd had to do that once and I
wasn't even doing it manipulatively like
genuinely I was like I can't take this
class again
I fully [ __ ] up and they passed me huh
they just gave you a pity a b-plus I
turned out that's a cucumber move but
there was he mine that was full cuke no
it was uh the the man was wonderfully
nice he said if you can really like
power out this next week and turn in
some stuff then I will evaluate your
situation so like I did something you
know wow you just FLC that's the
difference brutal honesty and and brutal
brutal lie yeah that hurt his [ __ ] like
a shitload cuz again it's like I'm not
pretending to be good at any of this
stuff but I feel so embarrassed you know
cuz I'm a proud person to some extent
but you have to just crawl on your hands
and knees and be like I [ __ ] up please
have mercy I guess is you know yeah I I
had the same college experience man it
was like I had to do what I had to do to
survive yeah but I had to like crushing
my anxiety was like I was I was barely
upper I could barely operate through
college so it's a miracle that I as you
say stumbled come due and by the way I
went to UC Santa Cruz not exactly the
most illustrious of the schools but it's
as equally shitty as you describe really
yours to be man ours was not yeah I like
the people there you know I think the
people are what makes any situation and
one thing that I really benefited from
was the copious amount of like free gear
and stuff that you could check out from
the library yeah like I did three years
of a YouTube channel and I didn't buy
camera I didn't buy a mic nothing cuz I
just go to the library and we started to
I used to borrow yeah we didn't know how
to use it and our for all of our first
videos hella crazy interlace the cameras
they had were like the complicated ones
nothing small and simple and we had no
idea so it was all wrong yeah everything
yeah that's mine too because
like I wasn't learning to [ __ ] in my
camera class I probably have like at
least five older videos that I shot as a
sketch and I didn't know about like
manual and auto focus where I would
check out a camera come on baby I hope
this blends isn't blurry oh [ __ ] well
guess I got a shoot on it I didn't know
what focus you know yeah so I guess we
had like the white balance on auto and I
didn't know and we would record inside
the house and made like sin it would
start changing completely all the colors
and we were like why is it doing that
why is it it went from orange to blue
like because of course everything you're
making is a masterpiece do you think
you're like oh dude I was gonna be so
famous from this yeah the worst thing
ever with each step up to you notice one
thing in disregard the blatant bad [ __ ]
so once I figured out the focus stuff
was like wow professional and it's like
the white bounce was on like cloudy yeah
but it's Chris audios like so back yeah
yeah alright let's throw to a quick
break I am going to go eat a bunch of
bagels and cream cheese mm-hmm and we
will be right back so guys do not go
anywhere oh that's what we're working on
the substitutes though right yeah make
sure to keep that going are we bump in
yeah we'll be right back we'll check in
on that I'll just break thank you guys
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets
you buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
cryptos all commission free while other
brokers charge up to $10 for every trade
Robin Hood doesn't charge any Commission
fees so you can trade stocks and keep
all the profits plus there's no account
minimum deposit needed to get started
you can start investing at any level the
simple intuitive design of Robin Hood
makes investing easy for newcomers and
experts alike view easy to understand
charts and market data and place a trade
in just four taps of your smartphone you
can also view stock collections such as
100 most popular with Robin Hood you can
learn how to invest in the market as you
build your portfolio discover new stocks
track your favorite companies and get
custom notification for price movements
so you never miss the right moment to
invest and here's where it gets real
guys because Robin Hood is giving our
listeners
restock like Apple Ford or sprint to
help you build your portfolio to date
that is insane okay if you've ever been
interested in investing or trading you
want to learn robin hood's the place to
do it sign up at HTTP podcast Robin Hood
comm you get a free stock on Robin Hood
you're gonna learn what the heck is
actually going on here on the stock
market if you're good your new original
whatever I don't know just get on get on
over there look guys sexual performance
issues are more common than you think
one in four guys suffers from Edie but
it can't be treated
Edie that's when your dick stays limp
and never gets where you want it to be
okay over 25% of new edie cases are guys
under 40 but why do we turn to weird
solutions like eating rhino tusks maybe
the Chinese people are literally turning
animals extinct in Africa trying to get
their dicks hard we don't need that we
have actual medicine okay because now
we've got four hams calm a one-stop shop
for hair loss skin care and sexual
wellness for men forums provides
convenient access to US doctors online
in real medicine dispensed from American
pharmacies silde naff I don't know how
to say this SIL 7f Hill the active
ingredient in Viagra can be prescribed
for men online and delivered right to
your door it's completely confidential
and discreet no more awkward in-person
doctor visits or long pharmacy lines you
can save hours by going to forums calm
being your best means performing your
best it's hard made easy also featured
in GQ men's health Esquire Playboy just
to name a few if you're want your dick
to be hard because it's too soft you get
your first month for just 5 bucks will
get you started for just 5 bucks while
supplies last
see the full website for full details
and safety informations this could cost
hundreds if you went to a doctor or
pharmacy so go to forums comm slush h3
Edie yes that's h3 Edie fo are hims com
/ h3 Edie to get started for 5 bucks and
short we're gonna make sure your dick is
hard as a rhino tusks and you don't need
to eat a rhino tusks to make that happen
before I'm cops let's rage 3d
reading is one of the most important
beautiful things that we as human beings
can do to enrich our minds and our souls
but we don't all have time to read books
and that's what's so special and
beautiful about audiobooks is that you
can now multitask in this busy world if
you're exercising playing video games
relaxing working you can pop on an
audiobook and enrich yourself while
being productive that's a beautiful
thing it makes us smarter and more
connected there's no better place to
listen on then on audible audible
members choose three titles every month
one audiobook plus two audible originals
that you can't hear anywhere else just
go to a You DIBL e.com / h3 podcast or
text h3 podcast - 500 500 and browse
their unmatched selection of audio
content now the book that I'm gonna
recommend to you guys here is catch-22
if you haven't read this book if you
don't know anything about this book it's
one of these American classics that it's
like I talked about Kurt Vonnegut a lot
it's very similar style it's about the
insanity of war but it's just this
unbelievable black comedy that is both
hilarious and Ricci I open it there's a
new Hulu show coming out later this year
about catch-22 that I'm super excited to
watch but if you have never read this
book I mean it's it's a pressure it's a
beautiful gem and you are just gonna
absolutely love it so fantastic you can
also listen for free start listening
with a 30-day trial and get your first
audiobook plus - audible originals for
free when you go to audible.com slash H
free podcast or text H h3 p OD c ast -
500 500 and you can listen for free
- Ethan say hello hello your life
wait you know you don't say hello I
didn't hear you coming in I don't know
what happened sorry Wow
so we were you can verify all right
they're nodding probably live your life
okay is it happening on it's on how do I
get to the live sub feed here how the F
white I thought this was easy to do and
they can just send you on this corner
guys welcome back this was an extreme uh
thrilling thrilling got right back into
it we did it
I washed my hands during the break as a
professional courtesy - thank you yeah I
appreciate that yeah you know I was just
the one time I will sometimes not wash
my hands but I feel like you should
always if you're at a situation where
there's no door like at a theater
sometimes they don't do the door they
just have the wall yeah that's my
favorite bathroom situation you just go
out and and you know you'll have a clean
pee and you're back in putting your
penis Hansel back in that communal
popcorn bed so well sometimes you can
maneuver it so you don't even touch the
old wean you know just cool you just do
the arrest the penis on the Beltline yes
and and trust that the repercussions
don't make it be like an open hose I
think I love that and you know what
really grinds my gears who got a sit
back for this one
okay so sometimes at even at fancy
restaurants you'll see this ah a
bathroom with the door no paper towels
to open the door they'll just have an
air dryer it's like hello I'm at a nice
restaurant and you think I am gonna
touch that door handle there's no way I
don't I ever use an air dryer ah Cobell
probably for [ __ ] years I haven't
used an air dryer it's a hair dryer
their journey and your you still get wet
me a [ __ ]
paper towel if there's a door plus in LA
you know if they don't have the clean
paper towel dispensers you guys have a
good one but most the restaurants are
like let's just throw a bunch of paper
towels so it's just like that'd be a
good sketch for you I don't get it cuz
that's LA so eco-friendly they're like
oh we can't do straws but if you go take
a [ __ ] you're gonna use ten paper towels
to wipe because you separate ten of them
you know hey is this thing
[Laughter]
oh we were we were discussing at the
beginning of the show yeah that link Gus
here is here we're making some probably
bumping we're bumping things out that
[ __ ] no [ __ ] you dude so guys we are
trying to give Gus here the h3 bump come
on there's enough you watching let's
show Gus what the h3 army is all about
let's lock and load baby Oh me later and
I'll walk towards public buildings with
our weapons let's walk to YouTube
subscribe button not headquarters
subscribe button yeah that's on your
page in your house not a physical
location that's okay the guns out hit
that subscribe button show them at the
age for the army is all about right you
endorsed that I endorsed that I think my
legal team picked through that step let
me ask you a question here yeah between
Chris Brown Michael Jackson and our Cali
[ __ ] Mary well I'm in so heavy to Chris
Brown already you know like what the
[ __ ] Chris Brown thing I did a video on
him god I don't know I might have to go
kill Chris Brown just cuz I have such a
history built up on him and like even
before the video I made a few months ago
like four years still I was like talking
about that [ __ ] publicly it just it
baffles me so much how he has alluded
any like public punishment or even like
corporate punishment that that's what
bugs me the most regardless of the
severity of each of those people's
crimes arguably are Kelly's seems to be
the most like heinous crime [ __ ] but
like I'm just in so deep for Chris Brown
well Chris Brown I agree because his
like with our Kelly and Michael Jackson
people debate it yeah with our Cal or
with Chris Brown we all agree he beat
the [ __ ] out of Rihanna right it's not
so I mean we've all seen the pictures he
[ __ ] like choked her did that nearly
to death yeah and even if it again just
to say oh just that one thing that is
the worst possible thing that should be
a career ender but he has had now 10
years during his professional career
where he has repeatedly been like
assaulting people right like you can
look up it's [ __ ] public records
right but all this it's it's it's
sickening how many fans he still has and
and just add a quick pass over it seems
like most of the social media accounts
they're like [ __ ] you breezy for life
stream undecided it seems like most of
them seem to be women like what the [ __ ]
is going on like I don't get it at all
pretty much right after it happened on
Twitter there was people like Chris
Brown could beat me and I wouldn't say
anything
yeah I what there's so many feet again I
and I outline in the video angers there
the thing is yeah he's a hottie with the
body good see dance if I could only sing
I can dance yeah I could sing oh you
could wrap them got that going for you
but ya know though he's [ __ ] hot he
can dance and he's a good singer and he
just gets a pass because of that I don't
get it do if you're if you've got the
triple threat you can beat up people
yeah and even diddle little penises too
if that's what you're into it yeah yeah
I'm sick I wish I had it no but I hear
you I agree with you about Chris Brown
that guy's been a scumbag for so long
it's just I think more than anything
even if you're a die-hard fan of Chris
you got to step back and go holy [ __ ]
how did he survive me too and not even
survive it but how did like no one talk
about him here right there is it in
collabs all the time when other people
and dude he's collabing with everybody
he's winning awards he's performing he's
selling albums and well he's like me to
he's like I didn't do anything sexually
I just beat the [ __ ] out of you
how many of his own fans do like they
have a plethora of defenses for him to
you know like you just you just hate him
or like you just being racist or like
you're just Regulus and stuff to yell it
yeah that's the [ __ ] but one of them one
of them do is for the Rihanna situation
I've seen so many people defend him and
go like you don't know she had a death
grip on his balls oh okay he was
defending himself kidding me come on I
love that that she had a death grip on
his balls where did that originate from
is that just a rumor
um people are extracting different
things from the published police report
you know like it's pretty in-depth about
her like fighting back you know and
there's just like people like bro there
was fighting on both sides it's like yes
she was getting killed let me ask you
this what somebody grabs your balls and
squeezes as hard as they can
what do you do probably hit him in the
face once oh you do see I would think
that you would go for the hand oh that's
true be like oh [ __ ]
yeah and he's much stronger than she is
with my luck though I'd go for like full
hand punch I just knocked myself but I
think instinctively it would be one of
those oh one of the republic's and then
you know then he would choke her to
death yeah that's true it's just too
calculated to be like oh you have a
death grip on my balls I'm gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of you it doesn't make
sense
I love the gripping balls ya know so
okay so we're killing Chris Brown so now
you have a Michael Jackson RK when you
have to [ __ ] it when you have to Mary oh
boy talk about a lose lose lose
situation here for all well win lose
lose if you're killing one of them I
think you probably [ __ ] Chris or [ __ ] R
Kelly he's got that sexual energy yeah
Mary Michael I feel like if it came down
that's exactly yeah if it came down to
fisticuffs at the very least I could
defend myself against Michael I feel
like Michael is huge by the way he's a
big guy oh no I saw him because he's
he's transformed his body and you
wouldn't expect it I saw him in a video
he's got like massive hands really he's
like a huge guy how tall is he he's tall
it's not huge No
with his he had like he's built like a
big-ass black dude he's I don't think so
Michael
Michael Jackson height I just looked it
up he's a five nine you just sign next
to kids though he's like Bruce Lee he's
like a little ninja yeah I can dance
that's on your grave he's probably gonna
press knuckle under the gloves too man
I'm looking at pictures of his hands
it's the platform shoes he seems someone
fuller I'm sure you know Plus what the
gloves your hands look bigger in the
gloves like everything's going for him
image wise for making him look to be a
big fella this might be the weirdest
thing I've done I'm looking at pictures
of Michael Jeff his hands do look pretty
big I saw them and I was like that guy
could you know are they d glove well
yeah Big Love you want to see his hands
yeah don't search degloved hand though
they do look pretty large like I mean is
he doing the ball gazer right there this
fun boom gotcha original that's where it
came from
yeah yeah they look pretty big but also
his face is tiny margin no they look
normal here I don't know what I saw they
were like bulging when I saw them well
what I thought was like you know what I
want I thought was like dude he probably
liked that thought it looked bigger yeah
that's a big that's like a big hand
what's those vitiligo hands down there
are those his or is that just another
person with vitiligo that's not him
that's not him no way cuz that's why he
dyed his skin right it's because you're
starting to get that or I mean yes yes
what he says yeah I don't know yeah I
don't [ __ ] know yeah but anyway how
do you bleach your entire body to like
that's a new procedure is it a tub like
you just get in a tub or something I
don't know I think they must have
scrubbed his skin ooh sounds painful
yeah I wouldn't do it guys Gus we're at
war at 997 come on h3 army load up those
shotguns
we're getting there HD army load up
those that what are the weapon that
everyone's contentious about the M's
they are load up those ar-15 get HP army
little h3 bump stock let's get a HD bump
stock over here load up those guns let's
get those Arsenal's and march on that
YouTube yeah we shouldn't joke about
that's s oh yeah I like that and I think
that Michael Jackson would be more of a
tender manag as if you've watched this
documentary you know he favored monogamy
even with small children oh yeah that's
what a weird sauce up of like yeah just
things I'm gonna check down the truck
that was good that was a good choice and
then our Kelly got that sexual energy
you'd [ __ ] like crazy yeah he would be a
mad lover he chained you up he'd [ __ ] on
you he'd piss on you all this stuff I
know you're into I don't know I could
survive that right we're bumping now
boys hey yeah would you rather a watch
bo he a ridiculousness
every episode of ridiculousness forever
yeah we're Bohemian Rhapsody reaction
videos forever that's I hate them both
[ __ ]
probably ridiculousness there's a little
moment yeah there's more parity I you
know it shocks me is there's still
people doing that bohemian rhapsody'
stuff to like yeah it's recent stuff and
it is so weird like I just don't
understand but they're getting clicks
cuz a lot of the ones I'm seeing now are
like I got 600 subs
there's 20k views like that's getting
pushed to people incredible yeah but I
think that there's just a demand people
want to watch people but so what I've
what you've pointed out and I've since
also notice is that it's mostly black
people it is yeah
so I wonder is it possible that the
black folks never got the memo about
Queen I don't know what it is maybe it's
maybe it's a pop culture divide maybe
it's just other maybe a few like black
youtubers started doing that they saw
success and then other people copied it
I really don't know what the with
and I should know because clearly I'm
very equipped to talk about black
culture I don't [ __ ] know what it is
but people are still getting clicks like
mad so that was a that was a fantastic
video for people who don't know you made
a video you notice a trend on YouTube of
people reacting to Bohemian Rhapsody
yeah and acting as if they had never
heard of queen or Bohemian Rhapsody yeah
reacting it for the first time they're
doing [ __ ] where they're like this is
from this band called like read - yeah I
the thing is like - I always get pissed
like one when friends and stuff do the
[ __ ] where you mention a movie and you
say I haven't seen it you haven't seen
that like that is that is reserved for
so few things you know like maybe like
you haven't seen Star Wars you haven't
seen Back to the Future like that kind
of [ __ ] but and Queen is one of those
things we're like I haven't heard of
Queen you haven't heard of Queen like I
don't care if you can list a song that's
almost impossible yeah like come on
every department store especially
bohemian rap you probably that song
might even be more famous than they are
honestly yeah even just the title of it
and yeah
it's just [ __ ] Stu but I love so even
if they let's just give them the benefit
of doubt and say okay you don't know who
Queen is and you don't know what
Bohemian Rhapsody is the way they react
to it it's two minutes go by and they
don't say anything - it's just them and
they'll switch to different part okay
okay are you doing they're not able to
monetize that right I can't getin
claimed the license holders just like I
love this [ __ ] dump
I just got claimed on a video yesterday
for a song that wasn't even in the video
just like it's [ __ ] UMG again so yeah
YouTube dude they're so annoying so they
have a problem yeah was their song at
the time stamp there was it was a
different song but it was but it was
because it was in my video did s and
I'll steal my idea and I used a couple
chunked up segments and during the part
it was Jonah Hill singing like Go Go Go
Joseph from Jesus Christ Superstar so it
was the wrong song wrong
a strong publisher and they claimed it
and it wasn't the timestamp didn't even
line up with the part that he was
singing a song in the video so just like
in every way it was inaccurate like what
the [ __ ] is still on it I talked to my
guy about this yeah apparently it is a
real claim he goes I'm like I'm like I
disputed this it's the wrong claim
everything's wrong about this and he's
like oh well there's a song in the video
so obviously you should just use your
brain to know that yeah written wrong
yeah I was like sorry your whole system
tells like I don't get it but I will
tell you this yeah if you had a song
appear in a clip that you were using and
that should be fair use yeah it should
be
did you dispute it I haven't yet it
happened a few hours ago
oh just happened yeah it just happened
but I'm doing it half those [ __ ] it
wasn't even like NBC that claimed it was
UMG again so you guys are the best love
them loving a lot yeah
UMG it's down it's almost sounds for oh
my god there you go
that was probably their business model
it's like I know how to give people I
hate ridiculousness I hate his giant
laptop set
I can't yeah makes me want to die I want
to I want to take the laptop as far as
I'm concerned clip shows ended as soon
as Tom Bergeron walked out the door of
AFV
drop the mic it should have been done
wait who Tom Bergeron guy
come on AFV host he now does Dancing
with the Stars he had a line Bob saggy
boy the SAG Pound was my one and only
I suppose that's his name Tom Bergeron
that's quite a name bird I don't even
know how to spell that there it is
there he goes thank you Google true oh
gee look at that look at that man I have
something to do with like the catch a
predator or something he does look like
Chris Hansen yeah Chris Hansen is back
now by the way and I have cuz I find I
think Chris Hansen must be one of the
most evil dudes in the world why like I
know
because first of all the guy first of
all I always kind of crazy it is crazy
if that show is just like the bottom of
society everything society has to offer
yes I mean Mike
well first of all Chris Hanson acts like
it's like dude you're not a [ __ ]
Saint that's true like what he's hiding
in plain sight and also he got in
trouble for adultery he treated on his
wife and I know that's not the same as
[ __ ] an underage person but it's like
if you're gonna act like the moral
arbiter like oh don't [ __ ] kids like
that's such a big deal then don't cheat
on your wife
mm-hmm just [ __ ] women yeah I think he
kick-started his show and it's coming
back online now yeah yeah because he
he's a Golden Goose baby yeah crazy that
they can make a show out of this moment
of that person like losing his life yeah
that's that's how we put it on YouTube
and it's trending or whatever it's it's
so weird cause it's like obviously I buy
into too I watch that [ __ ] like crazy
it's very much it's phenomenal way
fascinating it's like phenomenal
even knowing that these people did some
of the most heinous acts in society that
they potentially have ruined other
people's lives before this and stuff you
can't help but see them in that hot seat
and then just feel horrible that like a
life is ending again no pity but you're
just like watching it's just that's the
end of your life because this shouldn't
be a show this it shouldn't be for my
entertainment and like losing his life
in front of me and you have like little
girl actors there who are like hey come
in did you bring the beer and the
condoms I don't know how anyone believes
that they're like they're like this 12
year old girl and it's just like this
Lani there's 25 year old theatre student
now the recent episode I saw it was a
little girl they actually got a little
girl oh really and the guy tried to hug
her oh I don't like that yeah I didn't
like they got cameras afterwards in the
police station
sorry not it they were interrogating him
and there was [ __ ] cameras on the
Tara geisha room that's got to be
something I always
yeah I don't know where asking you my
boys see him how did you approve this
show but I feel like there's some cases
that on the fringe okay mm-hmm and I'm
not a nut first of all I'm not trying to
defend people I'm not trying to defend
these predators but what is wrong with
having sex with kids come on
back to you but like let's say sometimes
they show like a really awkward let's
say 25 year old yeah he's like super
autistic super the guy's never [ __ ]
he's never had a kiss he's never
interacted with a girl and then he's
going to meet a sixteen year old who is
flirting with him like cope like
ridiculous over-the-top flirting this
guy has never received attention like
this before
mm-hmm and he shows up to her house this
is probably a fringe example but I'm
sure stuff like this has happened on
that show and then he shows up to this
house this desperate pathetic soul and
then it's like you know then the whole
song and dance happens and I'm just not
sure that it's deserving he's deserving
of all of that I think that I can see
how that situation would happen I don't
think it makes it like right I could see
how that could happen
definitely not right but it's good that
I think it's good that he gets chastised
like that the - and even though it's
extraordinarily uncomfortable like it
sets the tone it sets the message you
know especially if we're able to like
hear backstory from him and like realize
like oh [ __ ] you know maybe this guy is
like kind of on the spectrum maybe he's
just very socially awkward you know
maybe that might resonate with other
people that were even kind of
considering something similar like so I
just there's so much gross it's just
lying to me the whole thing is climbing
yeah I still think that guy's deserving
of yeah of getting [ __ ] nabbed though
cuz that's gross and regardless of like
where he's at in his headspace bad take
the only thing makes me feel icky it
does because my problem is that there
shouldn't be a show from this moment
this isn't entertainment
yeah I'm so glad that I'm not like
surrounded with that kind of media thing
too because like that's kind of Chris
Anson's thing that's just gotta be
stressful even he's being associated
with that kind of [ __ ] no he's not
stress he's way too comfortable well he
loves it he flourishes he does seem to
yeah I've seen you know I love the way
he talks oh boy first of all why don't
you tell me what you're doing I love
that when he has his like superhero
quotes that he comes in with you know
it's always as soon as he emerges you
know like you know he's back they're
like really cool today so I was gonna
say I think the the people that get
caught had to like sign off on it to
give oh that's what I thought because I
believe that's how it works on shows
like costs but I just looked it up and
apparently they get away with it because
To Catch a Predator it's considered a
news show it's not an entertainment and
they don't have to follow the same rules
but it's like it clearly is because who
would sign that's how they kind of skirt
that rule and they can show these
peoples well they know whatever suit
that so yeah I'm curious well how are
you gonna sue when your life is already
ruined it's like well you get a lawyer
who sees gosh yeah you some of your
commissary money at the prison yeah I
got 20 bucks on it
yeah look if Matt Haas can get someone
to sue us his was personally hired
though right no imagine wait his was
like a public defender
no it wasn't anybody we get up you get a
lot of times you'll say hey let's go
after them and you get 50% of the
settlement oh that happens a lot when
you're suing big corporations yeah
people don't have money whoa so this is
pretty dark when I googled lawsuit
related to catch a predator the first
thing comes up is that NBC had to settle
with a woman who sued them for 105
million dollars because her brother was
caught on the show and committed suicide
because of it oh can we agree this shows
a little yeah that she went in or they
settled so so yes yeah there you go
god what a mess of everything I'm so
glad that that's not my brand
it's just like [ __ ] right even even
though these people are like clearly
pretty goddamn desert
see good Christmas I'd kewlabah saying I
would do I would be you know be funny to
do is like watching tic toc videos with
Chris Hansen I do it up as I do with
Chris Hansen you could almost just I
would almost just want to take him out
in public and have him ask people to
take a seat I can't walk around with the
chair and gonna sit down cuz everyone
else watching knows it's him and knows
what's happening he has like that
mystical power like him when he Chris
Hansen tells us to have a seat you have
a seat yeah dude it's that full dad
energy on the seat you know I'm
cultivating disappointed dad like
anything else dan I'm curious because
there's like even more at feeling most
of the articles are about this one cuz I
guess this was pretty this is actually a
while back to is this 2006 is when he
committed suicide
Dan's oh yeah I guess that shows been
running for a long time hasn't it Tom
Bergeron is as tall as Michael Jackson
let me look up pictures of his hands
really exposing myself as a weirdo today
Jesus that's fine yeah what do you do
what else we got here what else we got
here that's my new thing that everyone
laughs at me for saying catchphrase put
on a shirt Kelly so I was gonna there's
a couple things here I got mmm-hmm
YouTube haiku is also where I started
really I did not know that yeah that one
but how when was that it was a long long
very our channel in fact I can show you
a couple of examples but I think we I
think we had the same came to the same
conclusion cuz I was on reddit a lot yes
and I was trying so hard to get you know
people watch my videos and I you gotta
almost when I figured out was like find
niche and then make content for those
people yes you definitely do reddit is
is just such a toss-up I was looking at
the question thread in your subreddit
too and I noticed one dudes question
actually that and he had said like Gus
how does it feel like with the creation
process
on reddit and like especially like you
being kind of a controversial creator on
reddit and I [ __ ] controversial I was
I started to think did I miss something
yeah yeah I just thought the thing is
that I've noticed with reddit and it's
been personally comforting to its shitty
that it happens but it's it's personally
comforting to notice that it is not
unique to me but I noticed with any
creator that starts getting regularly
featured on reddit you know I mean there
dozens of people there turning on you
that go through not yet is the thing but
I mean it's the same thing because I
went in those those peaks and valleys
too with YouTube haiku for a while where
it's like oh [ __ ] they like me oh my god
people don't wait I'm out of my [ __ ]
life yeah yeah I know it's like well
they like me again and then no I'm like
man wish I could break on to our videos
while they like me they don't they like
me it's [ __ ] up and down yeah and the
thing is like you'll see this if you if
you go to the bottom of any reddit
thread you'll see it with everyone
doesn't matter how awesome how wonderful
they are you know you're out of the
bottom don't [ __ ] go to the bottom to
stay away from the bottom it's hard not
to look and again it like guys to bump
me up boys what are you doing Vercetti
Jeremy I where's that harvest let's
march on Washington we're not firing our
weapons we're only getting them locked
and loaded which is our constitutional
right there's Mac that subscribe button
airsoft weapon right you endorse that
message the airsoft weapons no a ours
are the only logical motive with backup
ammo
yeah hashtag AR AR s for Gus car no but
you see it with like it doesn't matter
how wholesome a person is you know the
people that are regularly featured
currently a batch of that I would say is
like me pro ZD Ian kung binging with
babish you casually explained you look
at any of these guys like all the people
I listed are so [ __ ] overwhelmingly
positive and wholesome and stuff and all
the [ __ ] that they do but regardless
there is such a like a thread of belief
on reddit for so many people to think
like well each piece of content should
be made for me this was made
for me and I'm hiding behind a faceless
nameless username so if I didn't like
this
[ __ ] you I'm adding my opinion in it's
so much more impersonal you know and
you're always gonna have the [ __ ]
that just resent you because you are
seen on there you know I mean it's still
oh it's an indication of overwhelming
public opinion if you're still able to
get top links and stuff if people speak
positively about you overwhelmingly but
like oh goddamn some of the most
negative [ __ ] has come out of Reddit
like we shoot down don't understand me
and you have been through we basically
had the same exact trajectory yeah
it's crazy I didn't even know about the
Haiku stuff either too so I started on
YouTube haiku and I had the same exact
thing I mean that was a great way to get
people just watching my videos to start
like that this is one of four seconds
good thing this is a gift for my think
so there you have it and but then people
started liking us in our videos and we
even one like youtuber of the year of
our videos one year like they loved me
there yeah and now well now sometimes
we'll do okay there but for the most
part people are like h3 mmm
get that my [ __ ] thing don't have a
lot of people it's just really yeah it's
civil it's simple people people on
reddit are [ __ ] and because on the
exterior you look around like oh good
guys
yeah but Dan they are [ __ ] a lot of
there's a lot of jerks there I've seen
the highest concentration of like
Internet negativity from reddit stuff
like separate from Twitter YouTube
comments all that [ __ ] and I think part
of it is just because you know again
you're so fully anonymous and then
another part of it is I just think that
that it's so easy to get that group
mentality with reddit we're like I was
watching [ __ ] who was it it was on it
was on Joe Rogan experience I was Kevin
Hart actually did you watch that one
recently I [ __ ] blip yeah where he was
talking about like it's it's so like
nowadays it's cool to be negative to go
against the grain would be like oh I
[ __ ] hated that that's what it is
it's not what it is it's like I've been
thinking about that so much it's
contrary 'n ism people it's cool to be
like a contrarian but also even further
it's
to be like nihilistic yes like it's it's
it's cool to not care about anything
yeah I did not take anything seriously
that's so [ __ ] true and I think that
somehow it's developed with these people
that would go in and be like [ __ ]
hate Gus I [ __ ] hate Bros Edie that
kind of [ __ ] I it seems like that point
of view is not only unique and contrary
in' it seems like when they're saying it
they think oh I'm on a higher mental
plane you know because like I don't buy
into all that I think that you should be
like this dumb stuff you know I don't
know what it is because also probably I
would be willing to wager 85% of my
audience at least has come from reddit
over the years you know I've had a I'm
proud of this [ __ ] I've been working for
four years to get to this no and it's
been grinding and stuff it's been me
even not doing shitty scare videos me
swapping out cameras jumping behind the
camera and stuff so that oh I don't want
you to buy CUDA see me so much so maybe
if I'm shooting it they won't know it's
me and I'll just sneak a little meme in
for that day get 20 subs and work day by
day you know bro like that's the kind of
when we got 10 subscribers a day that
was a big achievement I would look at
every single individual subscriber yeah
bro we had the same I'm telling you did
you ever have like who are some of the
very first early on like people that
like swoop like swept in and maybe gave
you a boost or something yeah I don't
know if you remember cuz these guys are
all kind of like ancient history you
know but um there was the MLG montage
guys they were the first to discover my
channel
do you remember snipers um just like oh
oh like sni p ARS yeah yeah dude I
remember them so he was like my snipers
was like my guy he discovered our
channel and then Ice tweet like he
invited me to his group chat and what he
was like gonna click with all the other
MLG montage guys and they started like I
would make him like green screens yeah
for it to put in their MLG's cuz they
would make this crazy edits yeah and
they're like can you just record fry
something on a green screen and we're
like sure elio that was everything yeah
so it was actually a really fun time
yeah
I do yeah but it was like man I remember
I remember one of my first bumps was I
used to make these video edits easy xes
yeah I remember those and I made one
yeah exactly
Ainsley Harriott yeah and filthy Frank
posted on his Facebook page yeah and I
gained like 3,000 subscribers in a day
and I was bro I was I was you for your
[ __ ] through the roof yes like oh I
can use it playing I was dancing when I
was in Israel I was you for it uh-huh
dude I love that [ __ ] yeah early on I
think the very first one that was my
first boost I think I must have been at
maybe like it was definitely under 20k
subs on YouTube hmm
and I started getting a couple
notifications from Twitter or like oh
I'm here because of Jericho like Jericho
sent me over Tucker he's a big twitch
stream guy and he was like maybe five
hours into just some stream where he was
looking at videos or whatever and
someone linked me to his stream and
someone had recommended one of my videos
and just him on screens on his stream he
goes Gus [ __ ] Johnson this
[ __ ] right here so funny like go
check him out guys go give him a sub I
got like 1200 subs that day I was maybe
getting 3 subs a day dude
that made my month I was like oh my god
like that kind of [ __ ] I need to be
better about doing that to more people
because I know how valuable that is
and that [ __ ] there's another one i
Tubbs actually really early on it was
like I was again maybe under like 50k
sobs and I was just relying on going
from like haiku post a haiku post to
hopefully get views and stuff and he
came in on one of my way old videos I
was doing this do-it-yourself good thing
and he just said hell yeah good vid in
the comments hello and of course all the
comments were like bro are those is he
really makes such a difference and is so
important when you just sign up
sweetheart about stuff like that he yeah
he's he's very proactive about support
in the first time I saw you was in that
video you guys made together yeah I have
got so much [ __ ] respect for him he's
been nothing but nice to me and he
reached out to me and fully was just
like I would love to shoot something
with you when I was like maybe around a
hundred thousand subs which is what a
[ __ ] nice unnecessary though people
don't know
in is that he is a [ __ ] such a
sweetheart
he's a very wholesome sweet guy yeah
he's got a big beautiful heart and head
and and he's probably got his AR loaded
right now he's marching guys we're come
on listen work out we're doing really
good here we're we're bumpin we're close
we're almost 2,000 away so I'm willing
to venture that there's probably 2,000
be watching this right now that are not
subscribed okay I'm definitely flat
edged right now so you're a time edge
you mean like you're on the edge I'm on
the edge so close to climax right now
dammit there's some bug because it drops
out for like 500 at times yes unnatural
but load up those ARS those aks get a
good vantage point where you can enjoy
the celebrations maybe I should stop
talking about subscribing what did I say
there you go slime that bun I got
something for ya I don't know if you
recognize this shirt at all you can see
by the back right here little peep
little peep I wanted to thank you and
post when he was on the show for showing
me little peep it's honestly been kind
of a meme on my channel it like for a
while now but I just so on ironically
[ __ ] love little peep and I caught
the episode where it was like shortly
after peeps death and most was on here
talking about yeah and I was like I'll
check him out oh my god like Europe
you're peeping in I'm peeping in [ __ ]
hard I love little peep so much that's
cool that's always happening way too
much it's happening a lot well I think
it'll relate it I have to tell you I
think it's related to what we've been
talking about is that people online now
get so much [ __ ] it's so overwhelming
and it's so hard as a human being
we're not equipped to deal with that
kind of of feedback and I think a lot of
people especially like rappers and these
guys who have like a hard exterior they
don't like I'm
giant [ __ ] I ain't got no problem
complaining that I'm depressed and that
I you know that I'm on antidepressants
and all this [ __ ] but these guys with
hard exteriors they are nodding not
often times allowing themselves to even
come to terms to be vulnerable even with
themselves yeah and so it will to damage
their image in and then it imposes upon
their own self-image point
oh stop when you did boy we'd lost
though somebody just locked and loaded
no I think yeah that's [ __ ] right
it's I think it is having so much - it's
just nuts yeah that one's some sad [ __ ]
it's always [ __ ] when you find out
about somebody after they die - cuz like
I had no clue about him but like goddamn
he just had a new single or the new
music video dropped today for his thing
Oh for real man feels weird yeah there's
a lot of you know there's drama in any
music community and [ __ ] - but a lot of
people are really taking issue with the
fact that it seemed like especially a
lot for people is existing vocal tracks
are kind of being like just I don't know
what the right word is cannibalized
they're they're they're releasing so
much there let's say they're taking full
advantage yeah and I don't know what
kind of contracts were signed I don't
know what kind of intentions - his
latest single was like it's him and it's
Makonnen who was a friend of his for
years
and Fall Out Boy's on the track which is
like I know people talked about like
being a fan of Fall Out Boy I think they
had wanted to work on something but it's
it's so weird cause like the single it's
called I've been waiting now they've
released two music videos for it like to
fully shot music videos which is [ __ ]
weird a lot yeah for any situation but
it's like in the song there is like
maybe one loop of peeps vocals that they
had and it seems so clear that it was
like a lower quality like this chunk and
they're like oh we got this chunk yeah
what do we just [ __ ] looped it at
four times and brought in Makonnen and
then through follow up boy on the track
that's a that's a song and it's like
it's two years after he died you know
like it feels weird to a lot of people I
don't know what the right moral answer
is maybe this is what he would have
wanted
feels really [ __ ] bizarre though you
know and a lot of people are kind of
voice and were like dude [ __ ] stop
doing this [ __ ] the tough yeah this
whole like Amy Winehouse or someone like
a holographic door yeah
what did she do that the danger weren't
we talking about someone who's gone on a
holographic tour who's past that is
either Tupac or Michael Jackson on
saying well they did it with Tupac a
couple years back yeah yeah I think it's
becoming you know you know maybe they're
doing one for Amy Winehouse too but I
know that they're doing a Frank Zappa
one that is Frank Zappa you probably be
down with that yeah he was actually
super down with it to the extent that he
predicted it would become a thing and
before he died recorded a concert with
the intent of it being a hologram some
day and this was in like 1990 or
something oh that's cool that's some
progressive yeah it Frank
yeah he was on another plane of
existence of a wine house hologram tour
who's that's just the weird thing is
like who's making money oh yeah yeah
it's like these it's like the record
company's own your soul now they're like
when you die we will continue to tour
your ass yeah they're doing that same
[ __ ] with even like traditional acting
stuff too like like artists are starting
or actors are starting to sign off say
like you do not have permission to use
my likeness or my voice in future
projects Wow they say that within the
next five to ten years they could take
existing audio clips of people as far
back as from like even the 40s and [ __ ]
and piece together bits of audio scrub
them up and make it sound like yeah
Marilyn Monroe is she recorded this
stuff and it sounds like her and it
looks like her you know I hope somebody
makes all again with me doing this
podcast when I die that we don't do you
think this podcast will be entered into
the National Archives as being
significant enough culturally to be
preserved for generations
the show will definitely not be entered
into the but no but somebody's gonna
want to do a hologram yeah
this episode is sponsored by I'll be all
doing spots a copy reads is all again
yeah that'd be sick for all the
companies that don't even exist anymore
it's like 200 you know would they be
doing future [ __ ] like
like you could pee you can pee in this
bottle and drink it is that a future
yeah I feel like that's a real thing
that's the direction honey's going in
these days I think honey yeah piss
bottles good I'm all over that
Debbi adult the dopest hiking companion
yeah that would be great
piss in your bottle I definitely pissing
bottles way more off in the night should
almost any car trip I gotta [ __ ] pee
in a bottle with people in the car I've
done a couple times with my girlfriend
in the car she [ __ ] hates it it's
like don't do that because I'm afraid
that I well so my two fears are mm-hmm
one I'm paying too much and the bottles
for overfilling yeah that's a that's
like terrifying yeah and then two I'm
almost guaranteed that I'm gonna get
pissed somewhere you know for you guys
it's already so easy to pee and you know
just make a stop anywhere you know what
I did one time no it's so easy we take
that [ __ ] for granted that's what you'd
have to do like in college too when
you're like walking around from bar to
bar sometimes if it's like [ __ ] was full
you just had the technique that you do
is you take out your cell phone and you
lean against a wall and then puts your
dick controlling hand over here and it
just looks like you're leaning against
the wall like babe I'll call you back
and so you pretend you're on a phone
call and then you just kind of silently
pee along the side of the building or
something like that you would do that
call it allegedly not the statute of
limitations are aids but I never peed on
a wall that's true well walking well
sometimes if you really need to sell it
if someone walks by you take a couple
steps back season am i right what we try
to like ricochet off the wall so that
was silently likes creeps down I got to
sit down into class you know how they're
doing uh what's that Skillshare they
should I take that sign me up
piss 101 no I almost every car trip it's
just it's just easier to just pee in the
car and keep going so what but the thing
is it's way easier to do it if you're
the passenger so I would usually hop in
the back
and you can't just like open up and let
let your member out because then you got
all that spill potential on your jeans
so you have to literally like a little
kid pull your pants all the way down so
that you got a clean zone down there oh
when you're in the car you go
you know I'm girls do it and do that no
yeah girls suck and boys rule duh
boys rule got'em when I pee and this is
another thing we bears to admit yeah
this isn't something I've done my whole
life it's a recent development
[Music]
I pull my my pants like all the way down
currently yeah in public because I no
not in public no no I'm not a man yeah
well but at home I'll drop trou fully
yeah because so many times so many times
like because I'm a fat guy in I wear
elastic waist shorts and like the
drawstring yeah show us yeah I do that
[ __ ] pull it down and then like it will
catch like a fold on the pants and then
you end up pissing all over yourself
yeah that's what's happening to me way
to us dropping trou all the way down is
it being a guy that convenient now illa
again that's a [ __ ] spectrum pizza -
cucumbers
well see well I I mostly when I'm at
home I almost exclusively pee sitting
down so that's a different way it's just
comfy you need a little break you know
I've what about wiping wiping my urethra
when I'm sitting down oh now I get in
there you're you're wiping how do you
watch our back I go I think I go
alternating you know sorry yeah I don't
want a flex on you guys but yeah cuz you
know you got the little butthole folds
and if you wipe all in this direction
then you got the little sleeper poops
that are hiding out there you got to be
sorry how cavernous is your [ __ ] I
get in there dog full well I don't know
you got to be thorough
so wait you're talking about I got it
from the side no I'll go front to back
and back to front and what always
bothers on hold on all your showing back
you come from here oh my arm is always
back there that's all you're saying oh
no how do you do that
lift my talking balls in one hand and I
slide under that just gets too close to
the bone zone there like you can well
yeah that's why I come and I lift I'm
not and I'm it's an art form that you
learn over a decade okay I got a hone
that skill but from the back is not is
not something that is compatible with my
lifestyle I would I would try it out
it's no I'm well I've converted people
I'll tell I'll have you know a lot of
people try to my way me like this is
much better
that's - maybe you should but also how
would you know they're not telling the
truth unless you give a little peep
unless I had a video that's true that's
unless they had a time-lapse of them
doing it several times yeah yeah sending
that video evidence for Dan to watch
please don't do this day daily I still
get multiple emails about people's
wiping today well you know it's one of
those things that I really enjoy talking
about but then a whole conversation you
got a [ __ ] they're there to wipe from
the front I don't know it's the only way
I know can I teach him connect can you
teach a man to fish when you don't know
how yes yeah oh and you that I don't
know how to fish you know I can only
teach I can only teach what I know and
only know what he knows that the true I
swear 1,700 away I mean for Christ's
sake come on come on Gus Johnson 1
million subscribers h3 bump right now
what is the HB 3 bump mean to you we
started a little over 5,000 away so I
mean we've made good progress we're
getting there we're bumping in guys I
work for four years do you want me to go
back to making anonymous scare videos I
don't [ __ ] think so give me 20 bucks
come on I'll do it oh yeah break is out
now too because they were defined media
so oh where they guys I'm out on the
street you're the only one that got
ahead yeah the only guy that was just
whittling away 50 dollars at a time I
got some videos I want to show you yeah
let's see them this is the fun part
quick enough
hell yeah business now I know I saw you
tweet recently about Lance Stewart yeah
I know you've seen this video so they
made a video where they broke they break
up and then they made a video saying are
we getting back together
now let me they act like they are just
randomly at his house these
[ __ ] are wearing the Sam
ultra-rare red hue said Lego
that's bro that's the exact same shade
of like I want to say what kind of
burgundy yeah they're yeah I was I was
joking that because of Teddy fresh we
got these really big beautiful Pantone
books which like little cloth swabs
thousands of them the exact color and
all the colors have these really
wonderful names yeah so now I don't
I no longer will say green it's like
seafoam green vector I'm here an hour
what well no it's a beauty it's a really
beautiful burgundy red but that is not
something you just find on the racks
that's a rare Rhett and somehow these
[ __ ] match like they just got
out of like they're like they're gonna
drink kool-aid together in a weekend at
all you know yeah I don't buy it that's
all I wanted to say about it Lance
always looks like he just got done
sobbing in his car oh and there but have
one ear plugin that's definitely like
that's definitely a death cult where
they eat one earbud in they're all
wearing burgundy yeah you see your old
gold outfit no I didn't see that one
that's the one where they're breaking up
hit me with that hit me with that sound
effects axe yeah Thank You Lance Stewart
were breaking what's my saddest outfit
looks like she's about to go on a
spacewalk yeah she looks like a diva
here and he looks like the bouncer for
her show
whose voice was that already I like in
green sound like Kermit only right here
only a it's wonderful here let me play
it for you looks like she looks like the
lining of a satellite I don't know what
her name is but I bet a 10,000 that her
name was either Cindy or Miranda mmm is
it fun yeah she looks like the mom that
looks to see the manager at every
restaurant you know how old is she
it's like an insulation layer I think
she's like I think she's like 20 going
on that doesn't sometimes Lizzy worst
Lizzy worse
he's though she's that strong brand
their last names worse that's the last
name first hey what's the 210 a woman
looking in Lance's thing with area no he
I think he had like a he was trying to
make a crew
I don't like team ten yeah here's just a
reed is it number that stumped
I waited worse doesn't that mean sausage
I think so like like brought first no
urs I saw this thing with Lance Stewart
a couple months ago I don't know the
dynamic of him I don't watch him a lot
but it seemed like his grandma was like
super sick and had this big health scare
sorry I'm trying to put that's good and
then he was like taking pictures of her
with like the breathing tubes and and
super sick and he was she just was
draped in his merch I was like yo swipe
up swipe up for new merch like it'll
make granny like feel better yeah bro
why did I not hear about that I love her
dad it's important there was one clever
cop had a great thing where his dad was
like dying in the hospital yeah Logs
with them I don't remember that I don't
remember that I dunno clever though
though isn't he from like Sweden like
yes yeah like that
like hey guys my dad is dying yeah and
I'm here in the hospital and his dad was
like just all [ __ ] time and look at
my level coppers I don't want to find
that that's during video looking it's
okay you know I'm not gonna do not fine
thank you well if he had put it on video
that would have been like what the [ __ ]
are you doing
did he do that I don't know I don't want
to touch this I'm too insensitive to
deal with this stuff right he'll either
stop me she's right yeah let's watch our
Kelly we can all enjoy he sings
wait is that recent that he's singing
paid up to a hundred oh yeah this just
happened because he can't get a gig and
he's like desperate to make money yeah
so and I don't think he can leave his
city either really he's from Chicago
right and this was in Chicago because I
was thinking yeah I think he's renting
and Trump Trump's Tower
oh that's amazing whole area is such a
great evil hideout you know at the top
floor [ __ ] brooding so fantastic so
you can't get a gig so they hired him to
come sing at some local nightclub or
well Chicago's not locally yeah some
mama
yeah ticket to watch him sing for 28
seconds
the [ __ ] are Versace da
I love you lyrics of his hit song bump
and grind the appearance was at a club
in downstate Springfield Saturday night
after singing Kelly with fans dancing
and taking selfies the 52 year old faces
a wait so we sang for 28 seconds and
then stayed for an hour and didn't sing
bumped and grinded that's what you got
to do you got to be efficient
his outfit sick good he's all Versace
doe he looks like the entire discount
rack at forever 21 just ran through the
whole thing that's true the card it's
probably $20,000 outfit honestly it's
amazing how much some people pay to look
so bad
the clothing as an interesting
phenomenon because it's like when you
become so rich to a point you don't get
a thrill from spending money like I when
I was really poor I will get the biggest
thrill from buying it you know a 12-pack
and some sausages yeah dude well that's
that's becomes meaningless so you have
to buy $10,000 shirt really to get any
joy of spending money that's crazy I
hope I never get to that level my outfit
right now the most expensive thing I'm
wearing is this t-shirts 25 bucks that I
got on a little TV shot Wow I know Steve
Hobbes my own clothes anymore
eally just make [ __ ] for me to wear no
that's the way to do I got to get Eddie
on that Eddie whip me up some hoodies by
the time I get back that's great
Teddy fresh is just a conspiracy for you
o to get me to dress nicer that's a good
that's a good plan these videos aren't
that good this one is good these ones
are awful that we just showed you so but
this one is good now have you been
following the whole phenomenon of the
Ethiopia do you have your shots oh yeah
you have your passport yeah okay good so
this is a continuation around the same
time I'm not gonna pause I got to not
pause the video here I go I'm pushing
play and I'm only pushing a 1 why people
give you [ __ ] because it's so hard like
okay everybody buckle up yeah there's
one-minute clip coming your way
and here we go
I'm starting it now
[Applause]
really he's probably have Mickey values
at and living color
[Applause]
that's ridiculous how did that not
trigger any red flags even back to end
he's just been sexy we got his whole
crew for exactly yeah I like those
colors do
[Music]
- go fast [ __ ] do oh my god they got
a prob support you gotta be 18 but were
flexible
[Music]
he probably owns the patent on this song
- like it's registered trademark
somewhere as are Kelly's like
recruitment yeah gotta be 18 boom oh
look at your your own recommendation
already has enough fantastic that's some
dope [ __ ] yeah I like that it's also
dark with him once you have the full
content yeah I don't know who on his
[ __ ] press team thought that that was
a good idea that interview to like oh
where he just mine him you know
everyone's just like Robert I'm an
entertainer love me put me in coach
I think of the people that defend him
you know grasped on to it there's not
many these days anymore is everyone well
enough people who pay honor bucks a
ticket and get selfies and [ __ ] people
gone crazy man imagine imagine people
wanting to like actually have sex with
you that's just nuts that is such a
critter
you know the proverbial in the
proverbial sense yeah I've just been
like there's this one clip we watched
recently of him all that audience
members grabbing his dick I was like
what wipe me off wipe my crotch off but
I was like damn yeah that's not so buddy
wants to wipe my crotch off yeah I
wonder is how did you ask I mean pays us
to do it yeah Dan doesn't like to do it
but we pay him I wonder like how much
this [ __ ] happened in like the 60s and
70s and 80s at concerts and stuff but
just like phones in the internet wasn't
around or groupies groupies yeah right I
mean across classic rock world men do
yeah how many of our favorite artists
today like the legends and stuff of that
classic rock would just be tanked for
today if they were from
you know they had women who would follow
them around on tour buses for the
opportunity to have someone piss on them
yeah who knows what the hell was
happening you know damn its damn are
they sad and and and those have you
heard of this instrument preachers and
sneakers no creatures and sneakers so
these are all super high-level preachers
but they go up on stage to do their
preaching and they're wearing the most
obscene designer clothing so here we've
got this is like like modern-day Joel
Osteen [ __ ] forget the kids hi bees
priests oh my god this one's not that
bad there's some of these are just like
let's see like how can you on one hand
be a preacher a Christian man of God and
be wearing $1100 Gucci slippers I mean I
don't understand how you can hold those
two are they others not like he's
wearing a Gucci belt like that's not
even the $500 bail people know that
that's guti looking at it like a hide ya
know everything all these stuff that
they're wearing those aren't hard flexes
like yeah it's not sleepers with the fur
and no confusing of what that shoe is
dude I this is the kind of [ __ ] like to
an accelerated level that I grew up with
like again from a town of a thousand
people in Wisconsin Bible Belt USA you
know like the examples of just like
these [ __ ] oh my god that's
ridiculous
this guy is wearing were these
evangelical followed that's funny Red
October super rare super hype bees
$6,000 mother-effing shoe that doesn't
even look good - yeah I like that a lot
of these high-end sneakers - are like
BAM you're gonna look at this but they
just look like garbage that looks like
when nature is telling you like don't
eat this yeah I don't know yeah I grew
up around the stuff I grew up around
this kind of [ __ ] not at the Gucci level
you know but it was just like the
in a small town it's there's so many
goods and Bad's it's nice that you have
that good support structure for people I
care about you and then there's the
central things like the church you know
people come together in potluck and [ __ ]
in the school all the events everyone
knows what's going on but like everybody
knows each other's business and just the
amount of just [ __ ] shitty
hypocritical Christians and power that I
experienced growing up was just
overwhelming you know pastors that are
just like bashing gay kids and trying to
do like conversion therapy and [ __ ] and
then they get busted for cheating on two
wives you know
unbeliev tribulation that God gave me is
[ __ ] you dude yeah there's always a
there's always a loophole for the
Christians well that the Christianity is
built in with the with a loophole yeah
and that's the whole thing is that no
matter you can be a serial child rapist
but as long as you asked Jesus for
forgiveness before you died you all good
yeah it's just stupid as hell it's just
a bunch of people picking and choosing
and stuff especially at the small town
level you know you hear the sermons and
[ __ ] and like there's some [ __ ] I
shouldn't get into but like we had the
year before I graduated we have this
night called like Baccalaureate I think
and it's where it's more of a religious
themed ceremony that's optional for the
kids that are gonna graduate the next
day so they had a guest preacher come in
and he was genuinely like like Bible
Belt doom and gloom going to hell like
if you were gay if you are practicing
homosexual you are perfect you're going
to hell and there are people in this
room that I know right now that are gay
and you're going to help it's like
[ __ ] these kids are graduating
tomorrow like they almost made it out of
this congratulations thanks but it's
just like that's that's I mean it feels
evil doesn't it it does feel you become
with that level of like wick I mean it
just feels like so wicked yeah it's
stupid and then it's like you got people
like I had a mentor or a coach of mine
who was like forcing kids to pray before
matches and stuff like that and hold
held really like really you know
closed-minded shitty thoughts and stuff
like that and he gets [ __ ] fired
because he had porn on his computer for
years you know like that kind of [ __ ]
where it's just
like I did I hate it one of my favorite
quotes I think is Gandhi said I like
your Christ I do not like your
Christians you know and I have just seen
a swathe a [ __ ] yeah topical Gandhi
reference this I've seen so many of
these people in power just in in just a
personal small-town community that it's
just so turnoff were you grown in a
religious household
yeah very religious one thing I
appreciated though is my parents it's
such a huge commendations to them they
were a beacon of acceptance and
forward-thinking in this really really
close minded community my parents don't
really hang out with other people in the
community their coaches and teachers and
stuff and they were always like from a
young age so like hey you know if you're
gay or trans or anything like we're cool
just tell us you know that kind of stuff
like like just be open-minded for stuff
and we went to church every Sunday and I
go to youth group on Wednesdays and
stuff but it was never crammed down our
throats it was just like yeah we're
going you know and I argue are you
really just to this day do you really
sort of super religious I am just kind
of I think I'm so secular minded with
everything I'm trying to do right now
you know I really try to work as hard as
I can to be mindful of others and seek
out other people that you know need just
a little bit of attention and now that
I'm in an in a position where I have a
platform and I have the ability to you
know just do little easy things it's so
easy to just you know acknowledge people
say hi to the guy at the grocery store
talk about stuff and but I mean I don't
do it because God says I should you know
I know I'm trying to just stay as
grounded as I can because I'm just a
small town kid from Ohio you know
but yeah I don't do things like through
a religious lens I don't really think of
we go to church anymore no I don't go to
church anymore you ever feel like it you
ever say prayers no yeah when I'm gonna
die you know the anxiety attack II
there's no house pray like you know
second wind here boy
I don't know I just don't think about it
a lot for the truthfully for the most
part but that's good
I'm just curious you know I think it's
important to have a set of beliefs
not even like non-secular but just like
[ __ ] that you decide for yourself like
I'm gonna be this kind of person you
don't have to tie it to something I try
to live like that mm-hmm
but well it's interesting because I'm
from SoCal yeah it's always kind of like
there is that typical archetypal kind of
SoCal it's like everyone's super secular
nobody's religious and yeah everyone's
Jewish every person I've known is like
Jewish for some reason so I am curious
about what the experience is out there
yeah it's weird I'm it's so shitty like
in small towns too because everything's
an open secret too so like we've had a
number of suicides in just the last
couple years for a town of a thousand
you know to have even like a few severe
edibles like that [ __ ] is that's
enormous you know that's a percentage of
the community like killers like kids
killing themselves you know and I just
know that like so many so much of the
church is tied to like school [ __ ] you
know and it's just like it's a really
poisonous environment I can't imagine
being like a gay kid growing up in my
small town well how do you make it out
right everyone's telling you you're
wrong
[ __ ] you you know that's sad I mean I
hear a lot of gay people who came from
those backgrounds talking about it and
it's hard to empathize with them
completely and how hard it must be for
them but it seems like really just like
hell yeah yeah it's so weird to us it's
like the people that I even think highly
of in the community for like other
things it's like oh I know they have
shitty thoughts or like oh they have
like a gay son that no one they don't
talk to their family [ __ ]
excommunicate about can you but it's
just like what do I accept you he's
[ __ ] the males he's [ __ ] females if
you like the smell of your butthole he's
going in that's good don't hold you back
buddy yeah I love how the Christians say
that homosexuality is not naturally
occurring I'm like bro you have you been
to the dog park yeah like you don't have
to go far honestly I mean that's a
that's a literal fact is in every known
species of mammal there have been
multiple observed cases of homosexuality
like what
why wouldn't there be how do you just
look past time yeah you're just choosing
that Oh what was that where they said
the Ray was his name the
raywilliamjohnson no the the classic one
where he's like the banana it's evidence
that God exists perfectly perfectly
appeal it ray site let me let me find
this but I saw such a great rebuttal to
that yeah he's like okay the banana
perfectly made to fit in your [ __ ]
Ray Comfort yeah I think it looks like a
penis it's a perfect shape to go in your
anus the banana yeah yeah Ray Comfort I
love that wasn't the best refute of that
that a banana isn't natural you know
that is it like a man-made thing Kirk
Kirk Cameron the legend himself and Ray
Comfort what a name
Ray Comfort man what's the chance that
guy doesn't touch little penis dude what
did last name like comfort sorry name
like comfort it has to look at me and
there why they singer from a Bob Ross
painting it's inspiration it takes more
faith listen to these devious than it
does to believe in God you've really got
to ignore the fact it's funny how we
equate the would atheism are they on a
rug yeah keep it clean it's my theory of
where the soda can may have come from
startling from the Big Bang to explain
soda cans
from this bank issued this huge rock on
top of the rock was found a sweet brown
bubbly substance and over millions of
years of luminol crept up the side
formed itself in a can then a lid
and then a tab music and so I am because
we know if the can is made itself
spangled cans like that they blocked out
some of Pepsi just the pepper part this
is just C it's for proof you know don't
tell me what to do Dan that was kind of
rude I missed wrong I thought I promise
not to pause love how he handed the
can't occur I was editing this video to
believe the soda can happen by chance
well we don't have to guess we know that
we made yeah
lies a coffee right on the can hold this
cut this Kurt thank you he says
nightmare the atheists nightmare
nightmare if you go in first
you'll find on the far side there are
three grooves on the close side two
groups the banana and the Almighty God
has made it with a non-slip surface what
about a banana if it's true for the
banana it should be true for every
single fruit that exists on the planet
yeah otherwise your theory doesn't work
you'll finance with a soda can makers
placed a tab at the top so God has
placed a tab at the top this is one of
the dumbest things I think anyone's ever
recorded yeah so we cut it that way with
the [ __ ] tab that's right right
literally any other fruit would have
been a better yeah literally anything
but a man
is he gonna suck that ready easy to
digest Fred it's even curved toward the
face to make the whole process you're
fine so much easier
seriously cook the whole cream what is
this [ __ ] thesis here is this a gay
thing
it has 40,000 nerve endings and focusing
muscles that give it more than a hundred
thousand times of this ain't because we
made a can yeah
God made a banana with the same
engineering that we did philosophies I
don't know God seems like we made a
doper product dude I'd rather have a
[ __ ] can of Pepsi a nice banana hell
is smarter yeah yeah tell me that about
like tell me that about a pineapple what
am I gonna do with the pineapple God job
on that one idiot
it's got a built-in security system guys
I'm not joking I'm not [ __ ] around
anymore we're getting low on time
where's my bump guys we are getting low
on time and we are 1,300 away
guys I'm not privileged come on please
you guys please this we have we this is
so important thank you I love that video
good you know I love that I don't think
he clears the counter on a single bag of
chips I don't get no we were looking at
them yeah I wanted to show you a couple
more of these preachers with sneakers oh
really good examples but man these guys
how are you gonna stand in front of your
people like look at this [ __ ] guy
yeah preacher and these are a Saint
Laurent class yuck look at this guy man
dude this is from like his own Instagram
or something but it looks like it you
think he put the deep in thought caption
on himself oh my goodness you I think he
did I think he did do that it's thinking
about God dude he'll do it you're
showing you're showing but you know what
these guys say they say that financial
success they sow it into their into
their theory yeah and and they sell it
back to them because they say favor and
God is represented by financial success
and all of these poor people that donate
money they want to make money is
really a get-rich-quick scheme kind of
this whole god thing dude it is Leah's a
lot of them say donate money and you're
planning a seed with God and then by
giving us money you're more likely to
get rich dude yeah I'm calling my shot
here again cuz the next like kind of
longer commentary buddy I'm doing is on
Steve Harvey oh I know he's right he's
doing is that Bruce Springsteen that
looks just like it looks like Bono too
but no he's a preacher he's wearing full
he is this is so height beast out like
it's a [ __ ] joke
yeah off white shirt there's like a $600
shirt they should probably like $2,000
pants with the off-white mudflap and
then these were like Air Jordans or some
crazy fear of God collabs I mean this is
like a $10,000 outfit that's ridiculous
but off-white it's like not for your age
Paul's closet anyway sorry you're going
in on Harvey the creationist yeah Steve
Harvey why we still got monkeys door he
went on TV and actually said that here
we go final stretch were getting there
um I just think that I made a video
about super Harvey a while ago did you
really yeah what would you do what angle
just take just that he's an [ __ ] he's
a sex oh you the moral barometer
yes moral barometer the the thing that
he's doing now is he's got this new
series called his motivation series that
he shoots on his sets of his talk shows
it's like between shits you see like
guys with tech guys walking around and
he's just preaching to people and it's
that same [ __ ] brain-dead shaming
Christian shed like there's like
multiple videos of him just giving these
lessons that are just so [ __ ] ish
like he's saying like you know a lot of
people I'm not gonna do a Steve Harvey
voice you know take too much time you
see a speaker he's like a lot of people
you know they're always asking like dear
God like let me get this car like give
me a car that can get me to work help me
make next month's rent and that's stupid
you're not asking enough don't you think
that God can do this don't you have
faith in Him ask for the sports car ask
for ask for the down payment on the
house
like this is on you you doubt God that
he can do this start asking I did all
this [ __ ] and now I'm in this position I
just I hate this [ __ ] underlying
thing there's a lot of like celebrities
Wow that I think are like overwhelmingly
like good people though - you know I'm
thinking - the big people that like get
up on a hill and they're the motivators
and stuff you know the rock is hard into
that Kevin Hart's heart into that kind
of [ __ ]
but so many of these people never seem
to acknowledge the gross repetitive
amounts of luck that they've had in
their career you know they're just like
Steve Harvey's the perfect example that
he's like you guys I did this this will
work for you but you're too [ __ ] lazy
and you're not trusting God go and do
this it's just like well it's true
you're lucky as [ __ ] the belief in God
is almost like is super narcissistic and
think him like I am the chill I was
chosen by God to be here and that's why
I'm here
yeah it is very narcissistic because you
have to I mean you know success is the
culmination of you know or they say that
luck is the combination of time and hard
work yeah that's just stupid and then I
I hate that they never acknowledged you
know how [ __ ] lucky they are and they
they act as if you know you a shredder
bitin [ __ ] he's a good guy never do
anything wrong you see this that this is
an epic [ __ ] party pop oh yeah we
don't know what we don't know what's
gonna happen but we bought this for you
okay and I don't know how you read the
instruction okay and tell us what to do
fill that bag up instruction tear down
the seal along the direction of the
arrow
aim at the angle of of 80 degrees not
your [ __ ] all right between sky and
ground then troll it what the [ __ ] I
don't know warning not suitable for
children under three years that's a
pretty long view for yeah that's not me
boys I don't even know which end is up
Tarrance guys we need 800 this thing
might explode what the [ __ ] does troll
I mean that's like the better blind roll
it I don't know you mad bro
Oh [ __ ] pop off there yeah Peters for
sneakers oh there's one more video well
you guys all make multiple accounts and
subscribe do what you have to do there's
one more video I want to watch before we
celebrate yes sure subscribe ten times I
made accounts for him Staples announced
their new logo and it's the most
dystopian hilarious thing I've ever seen
okay
imagine you're just a Staples employee
and you get called into a conference and
then they want you to watch this alright
I'm not gonna talk and I'm not gonna
sponsor all you guys subscribe you can
pause likewise
down the trachea
[Music]
[ __ ] motivational dude holy [ __ ] Lion
King music dude [ __ ] Office Depot
OfficeMax all that nothing on this okay
oh my god that's like the [ __ ]
mind-expanding me goddamn the light show
and everything yeah the chairs the
conference chairs back then whoa dude
did they just tell them to stand up yeah
yeah baby I'm still not gonna get paid
minimum wage yeah I'm just here for the
time and a half Wow that was a so epic
wasn't it what is there celebrate their
stuff just went up a thousand percent
goddamn logo like what who [ __ ] cares
about a logo redesigned no variety no
not that stockholders not the community
anybody the Staples community whatever
this guy's not even wearing all off
light
that's simple is it yeah how much are
his poor voters if you're on stage and
you're not all off way it's awful
actually I hate it it's just a staple
and now just take the spacing bugs me
you know is half a square this staple
takes up so much space mm-hmm it could
be like it could be like under the
staples or something and I like that the
old owner it was subtle like hey
Harrell's a little staple your old one
now I'm confused so L was like that bent
staple and they're named up again and
then it got the boner on stage it
reached staple perfection see yeah
that's a cool logo that's so much better
it's a good font and it's just a little
like good it takes so much more it's a
more complex this is dumb they're all
done this is worse and it's the colors
worse and they went from our
that's like what is the difference
between the art TM I don't know oh man
they went they went are on us there was
nothing with you oh they want TM on us
you know I stood holy SH a much to
handle this boy look they got little
staple desks damn mine if their stocks
down and this is the answer man don't
dump your staple stock now hell yeah I'm
a sucker for a good brand name or logo
though but this is just not doing it for
me you know I was pissed when Pepsi
changed their logo I loved that scene
that old Pepsi can that got me going
with that big gaudy font I like that
oh yeah Pepsi oh that's the old logo
yeah dude look see that Ultra even that
clash up on a thing yeah I don't like
this the new [ __ ] that's the new thing
is that swoopy one is that the Obama
font from the whole campaign those new
swoopy one that old [ __ ] right there
that mid-2000s this one crisp that's
good all that old stuff is good that's
me squeaking so worse the new worse the
worse which one's the new one new one is
that stupid novel oh yeah oh man they
looks like a yacht club or something
what is this font just lame it looks
like a it honestly looks like a premier
preset I'm not about that do you guys
ever get like sponsorship offers from
Pepsi after all the like Pepsi Max stuff
that you guys about Papa John sponsors
ever
well I reached out to them how did they
not what did [ __ ] [ __ ] dropped about
you know what happened what stoppage on
got [ __ ] hit yeah he got out from his
company's in the [ __ ] because he's
like oh I'm gonna give Tom Brady money
Tom Brady makes out those kids that was
Papa's rationale I had we even had our
people reach out and they connected
really and they said no not right for a
brand room why yeah but meanwhile our
guys gonna go drop some hard arse at the
conference meeting and stuff you know
yeah because he what the time he was
sponsoring the NFL yeah and then he
said no kneeling he said kneeling is
affecting our pizza sales really if he
would have and then that's when it all
went downhill for the Papa if he would
have got on the h3 train we'd be selling
pies in pizza heaven who the [ __ ]
doesn't like millenials have got to be
the main consumer of pizza [ __ ] it's
like it just seems like such a slam-dunk
home run for so stupid come on you
Millennials I described with our agents
not pitching it right or what because
I'm like dude I have a lifetime history
mm-hmm I have weekend pictures every day
of fans not anymore
like what not anymore it's I wonder why
the stocks down yeah it's literally one
of your most favorite catch phrases
[ __ ] Papa blasting yeah that [ __ ]
like coupon code Papa bless if that
actually were redic I would so so many
[ __ ] it might be worth another show
Papa Shaq yeah Papa Shaq Shaquille
O'Neal yeah you see the CEO know he's
the face of it yes they need it a bit
yeah damn
well let's celebrate let's do a five I
get away I'm gonna hit it we're gonna
hit it unless everyone takes me on how
the hell do I do this let's get off this
big boy popper and just at an 80-degree
please yes sorry I would never do a 90
rotate by arrow I just don't even know
how to [ __ ] do just remember to uh
what tear down the seal the whole
goddamn packaging is a seal is this just
a bomb that you got what if I died on
the [ __ ] AC and where did we get it
what's the story you asked for poppers
and I was like I think there's some in
the closet yeah when we celebrated for
something in the past maybe it was a
last episode of the year or something
but were these purchase from a reputable
source I mean judging from the
instruction that's a question tree do
you twist it I assume that you [ __ ]
twist it like it was trolling
just troll it yeah it's just right here
all right here we go 1 million crazy
degrees not that towards me right that's
super
wait what's 90 is straight yes 80 also
they don't even say in relation to
anything just like I love 80 80 would be
okay just if you could do it right into
your face here we go boys
I'm [ __ ] scared dude it smells like
come from in the label said there's no
gum do you think they have standards
over there at the throwing factory that
was even try to trap Barry
congratulations Bo 1 million subscribers
we had a big milestone it's so important
are you wanna that's a bear yeah oh good
you got a backup troll yeah that's good
did you hear it hiss for a second though
yeah was it good it's hissing
[Applause]
1 million it's such an important
milestone thanks dude I've hi I
congratulate you I am happy for you I
appreciate it
can I just say end of the podcast thing
to this specifically the million thing
has been a goal clearly of like any
youtuber stuff there's been a goal of
mine and also just being on the podcast
has been kind of just like the beacon
goal for me for years now that's all I
told you I'd go back and forth getting
those shitty donation bin like bags and
stuff like I'd be listening to every new
episode of the podcast I'd be I'd be
rollerblading at night and you know
sitting on a couple thousand subs like I
get on the podcast I want to do that too
so I appreciate it very much this is a
very nice thank you so much who in one
situation so thank you guys thank you
for coming I appreciate you I think
you're a talent thanks I think you're a
star oh you
I think there's Bonnie I think you're
humble I think you're sweet and a sweet
kid that I definitely if you and you are
18 I would definitely get you a shot and
a passport so anyway yeah I mean a
million for us was like it was we yes
just it's weird it's weird yeah I don't
want responsibility now though it's
official I guess it's official
yeah no what is that one and we should
celebrate the end of the show at this
point in the show nobody's left watching
so I can just not Brook here I'm not
gonna pause this one's really special I
want your hot take on this one of the my
friends from my hometown his family
somehow Matt Garth Brooks like a decade
ago and they spend every summer at his
mansion what yeah what do they think
about him they say he's nicest [ __ ] he
probably is but watch this video anyway
you know anyway but but but Trulia and I
do want to express that you know
Congrats bro thanks Appalachians Thank
You Jay it is a he
deal I appreciate it yeah and there's
that soundboard and it's the first of
many to come
here's hoping you never know sketch
comedy stuff people come people go yeah
but you got it all you're the treat you
you are the triple threat you got the
song you've got the comedy you've got
the sketches you've got the reaction
videos that's true trying to diversify a
little bit so you know yeah yeah a
little off-white is my problem so give
me give me your heart take on this okay
now that you have now that you have oh
you don't have a million yet so I'll be
equipped to talk about it well soon as I
hit a melee but then my word can you
have a million subscribers well I guess
it's official
we're now on Facebook I really wasn't
sure about this at the start but then a
friend of mine said something they just
made all kinds of sense
she said think of it more as a
conversation oh yeah I like that but I'm
already finding out on my own
so it's wiping the walls out between you
and me and I really like that it allows
us to do each others worlds or I guess
in my case hotel room it's really good
Brett I think about things I want to
post I want to post cool stuff slick
stuff neat stuff but most of stuff I'm
gonna post is gonna be raw stuff like
this raw this is just who I am
so this is truly a conversation tonight
let the conversation begin what the [ __ ]
does that even mean
so that was the last video he ever
posted the first the first and only and
last video he ever posted to Facebook oh
my god I mean that's just short
conversation it's a short conversation
there yeah it began in the dance
I'll ask my boy about him I got a hookup
I'll ask my Brooks guy you guys got a
birthday god I'd love to have Garth
Brooks as a guest W this weird as hell
yeah well those old country guys you
know they got to be creepy well they
yeah he had kind of has the preacher
thing at least because they're like I'm
just a good old boy yeah in my job
struck but he you know he he has like
$10,000 snakeskin boots
yeah Ike has a private airplane and he
makes songs I'm just a good old boy I
can't afford my baby's ring it's so
weird like that's the whole theme of it
it's just like really humble [ __ ] and
all these superstars thing about it you
imagine if you made an honest country
song
just flew on my private jet and [ __ ] the
bunch the prostitutes didn't care about
it a bunch of blow you can afford to be
my friend
yeah there you have it that's it so
let's sit in silence what are we at
listen silence says we wait country boy
hit me with that country swing I'm just
an old country boy who likes to do blow
up hookers butt cracks and I'm and I'm
not talking about those dive hookers no
I was talking about those $10,000 an
hour
private escorts the [ __ ] YouTube use
music library yes dude I did my my April
Fool's Day meme I did a full conway
twitty album that I covered mmm yeah
clearly dead in the water
there was just like dog what do we do
with this [ __ ] you know yeah that was a
tough [ __ ] yeah that one got I think
that one got 79 percent fewer views than
all the rest of my ten videos like in
those the today algorithms a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass I hate that algorithm it's
some [ __ ]
I hate it it's some [ __ ] but all right
well we're just gonna sit here silently
okay me with that country is about like
a PBS plug it looks like I just tried
the EMT for the first time
I tripped major balls on my private
plane to Vegas I took a bite out of the
pilots neck and wampum balls on DMT the
policeman showed up the airport I gave
them each a million bucks to forget
about it telling me sing now they say
you can sing what the [ __ ] oh yeah I
don't know you tell you I have the voice
of an angel
oh dude sleeper hits on me yeah I like
that you know how it is
then can you imagine Garth Brooks like
it's kind of like a new genre like hip
hop and yeah it should be a total weird
like country flight it's no it is
it's called hick hop that's what they
call it yeah it's hip-hop
yeah it now it was that one that one guy
was a part of that got bumped off the
Billboard what the little na sex
whatever they ki into expert on all that
yeah what was that show he was like a re
honest an account or some [ __ ] early in
at please don't let us say something
nicki manaj stan account deep cut
dude he did a genius video that has
gotten this got like a fuckload of views
really I like five million views in a
day
god damn dude those genius videos get
stupid views yeah
the backpack kid was my favorite
everything yeah uh oh I thought I was
thinking of the flossing kid yeah yeah
I was blown away with that that video
existed I just wonder why that shit's
getting pushed so much some channels are
killing it like nuts right now and it's
like that doesn't make sense like the
office YouTube channel and the Kitchen
Nightmares YouTube channel are [ __ ]
slang TLC - oh my god it's ridiculous so
the only thing that matters as far as I
can tell is I mean thumbnail and watch
them so if you have a great headline
dude like these guys have so much to
pull from like TLC and all these [ __ ]
like yeah this fat [ __ ] this 600-pound
man his dad bathes him and yeah whoa and
they have like the craziest thumbnails -
was like this huge dude with like with
like a dude washed him with dishsoap
yeah I'm pouring Carl's jr. cup over his
head like whoa I have to click that you
got you can't not watch it it's the same
[ __ ] with the kitchen I'm yourself and
half the stuff is just recycled [ __ ] you
know all of it and it's like the
turnaround time is quick like one month
you'll be like Gordon yells at owner for
bad pizzas and the next one is like
worst pizzas Gordon ever saw totally and
the clip itself is ass like it's all
live up to the title at all it's
horrible I think the Kitchen Nightmares
channel has five billion views on it
they're on trending all the time and
it's like go get on trending for the
exact same reloaded content they did a
month ago it's not Gordon Ramsay is such
a beast
that guy's a workhorse man yes like a
million shows that would stress me out I
couldn't be him look at his [ __ ] face
he's still hottie though dude yeah yeah
he looks better as he gets older they
look better they get money
oh I lied 1.8 billion dude Nitin sorry
just them just a measly 1.8 billion my
bad I'll leave that more views than me
that's true
same here channel [ __ ] my [ __ ] my open
mouth do you guys get a billion views
yet yeah we crossed a bill oh yeah when
was that
was a while ago actually but we haven't
we haven't posting that much in our main
channel so I think we're at like 1.3 now
a bunch of [ __ ] losers but I mean all
of our channels I think we're close to 2
Billy really I've had of my [ __ ] that's
been stolen over now it's it's probably
over 2 billion views total for stolen
links yeah you mean like Facebook how
they get like oh god leave you yeah
which are definitely inflated they're
like oh yeah this video has like 200
million bits like Facebook Instagram
[ __ ] you know that's a lot of views it's
a lot of yous cuz I think on my main
channel I don't even have 200 million
views total and it's just like all my
[ __ ] just get stolen like free oh what's
the biggest theft incident that's
happened to you um well I've I've had a
lot of companies steal [ __ ]
WorldStarHipHop is a [ __ ] scummy
company with stealing [ __ ] they've still
a lot of my big videos 9gag of course no
surprises that hang gig big [ __ ] dope
pull ahead by was there a specific one
that had like like 50 million kids or
something
I don't what my every cat at three am
video got stolen by I saw two different
links of it on Facebook with over a
hundred million views on each 100 so
like yeah but that's the no no credit no
credit no one ever got it and even if
they do credit it's like people think
they're like bro we're helping you out
it's like know how many people are like
what a great piece of content you know
Bob who made that there we go look at
that I don't give a [ __ ] by the way
they're profiting from depening office
well and you two are Facebook's
algorithm there's such [ __ ] slimebags
that if you put a link to the YouTube
channel or to your Facebook page even
yeah in the description of the video
they they won't share it they won't yeah
there you have to only put it on the
comment yes I mean that is it's [ __ ]
ridiculous and the thing is half the
Instagram notifications I get are just
people tagging me in seeing my stolen
content a while and it's the same thing
like now I have I've made 560 videos I
think and so many like probably 300 of
my videos are under 30 seconds meme [ __ ]
perfect I'm not even in most of them
it's the most stable [ __ ] ever so it's
like I will see different blips where
I'll see like oh my TV first
video got stolen and then I expect well
this next week half my comments are
going to be from other meme pages
ripping it from that Instagram mean
paddle that it gets lesser quality they
don't even know who made it like at that
point they don't know who made it it's
it's it's horizontal flipped there's
three water marks on it and it's in like
144 feet at that point I don't it's not
even good content for like it's just so
[ __ ] compressed you know it's gotta
be awesome when people put their own
water marks on your videos love it it's
the worst ever - cuz like or in the
early days I used to hit up those like
page admins and stuff and just be like
yeah excuse me you can't do that yeah
but of course these guys they're like
yeah they're immediate things like haha
[ __ ] you yeah I had to stop doing that I
remember early on like I would I would
confront these guys you say like hey I
need credit or I'll file a DMCA takedown
you know which which again I'm painting
myself to be the idiot nerd character
here but I like that legal because face
basically it's all Facebook and Facebook
and Instagram who's owned by Facebook
yeah you are
they make you the idiot for trying to
enforce your copyright yeah they you
literally hit a dead end on Facebook and
Instagram where it's just like report
this video why copyright stuff who's
infringed I am what's happening they're
using my thing to let it go end an hour
yeah billing this out and once you get
to the end you can't even submit a
report that goes they say um how would
you click this guide and learn how to
accurately report so it just says it
says did this happen this didn't happen
honey why don't you just look at this
it's like [ __ ] you dude you know YouTube
gets a lot of [ __ ] but they're the only
ones that are attempting to be fair with
this [ __ ] yeah guys can you please lock
and load guy want to [ __ ] some
subscribers we only need 100 don't be
cute and not subscribe as I said that we
all need 120 subscribers for [ __ ] sake
I have no interest to entertain you guys
anymore
today I'm not gonna try to entertain you
I'm not gonna pretend that there's any
resemblance of entertainment going on
here I am leaning back at it at 80
degrees saying angle
this our this is a mess dan in hand I'm
sorry you guys but you not only chose
the confetti kind there's straight
glitter in this too we have a vacuum
down how you guys you guys gonna be okay
that's somebody old you don't be funny
no because there's an office there's
someone from the office that comes in
and cleans yeah do you think they go for
it slip a fat hundred-dollar bill on the
door just like I'll put a 20 in the pile
yeah come on we pay we fasten a few
[ __ ] I'll go get it
I'm gonna go get a bagel if y'all don't
get it do you have any plans to
celebrate 1 million I think
whoa there's heart my heart's fluttering
I'm I'm doing more of less of a big bang
out video and more of Oh guys guys guys
this is it
[Applause]
[Applause]
and it only took me since September 11
2011 there we have it you're blasting
right by me so I mean are you doing
anything personal to celebrate like a
meal no friend out well I'll go out to
dinner with my girlfriend I'll I'll toss
back a cold one with my boy Eddie
Berbick subscribe dad and I got a couple
buddies from my hometown coming by
tomorrow just some guys I see once a
year so it's just I'm gonna upload yeah
I put this like thank you video up for
the millions just kind of going by
thanking different people in my life
that helped me get to this point it's
not a big are you gonna be able to make
a quick edit to add me into that so yeah
I'm just gonna do that to spend some
good time some good people in actually
sounds classic yeah it's a beautiful
thing how do you feel right now it's
weird
honestly like again this is goal one
into four years now and it happened the
same day like what oh that's very
flattering to you yeah absolutely thank
you you're sweet guy your real talent
subscribe ya'll are hopefully subscribed
you know this is we should just call
this episode subscribe to go yeah thank
you guys i've been watching since the
air conditioner is sexist that was my
first one
oh yeah yeah that was that was a good
entry that was back right after we after
we moved to Israel really or we moved
from is where we're at Isaac O'Neal's
house yeah cool it's a deep cut
thanks for everything on guys Thank You
Man I should the appreciate that you
washed our [ __ ] yeah thanks for the
bump everybody to actually bump works
the armies out there the armies out
there they can mobilize quick so to
anyone who's thinking of I'm just saying
that we've proven here today that we can
mobilize and quick and I'm not saying
that any of us own ar-fifteens which are
completely legal to own emotional states
but at what I am saying is that those
are metaphorical weapons some of
may also have weapons I don't know what
they physically have in their house or
not but I'm saying that we
metaphorically have the operator at
capacity and the will to mobilize quick
and fast and furiously at the march on
any location this is a threat all right
oh yeah awesome thank you guys so much
for watching that was fun fun fun times
a great cherished episode good memes all
around yeah fantastic awesome awesome
alright well have a great weekend - even
though today's went T is Wednesday right
it is go eat a bagel I'm gonna go chill
at home I'm gonna play blood-borne I'm
we should I I just I'm working on
stardew valley - I got inspired by Bobby
Lee's in there for you - Tareq check it
out I'm [ __ ] diving into blood-borne
because I want to do that before Sakura
or Sakura yeah I'm doing the exact same
thing so you haven't started blood
haven't started yet started I downloaded
it last night I've just been playing for
like three days
the beginning is is so [ __ ] annoying
by the way once you get past that then
then ik is my okay I heard I was a boss
right in the beginning it just [ __ ] you
it's just like stupid so I would just
say just just grind out some levels okay
yeah don't get this hard just grind out
some levels I'll do it you know save up
some blood get the starting armor that's
big and just grind out those levels you
know happy right damn
yeah absolutely yeah so we've set it off
we set it off subscribe to the Gus and
Evie podcast - we do our own podcast
there you have it boom there it is
that's all boom all right shut her down
shut her down thanks guys bye everybody
alright
[Music]